there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey here we are once again and it's
saturday
yep look at we have we got the lights
really good today for some reason yeah i
don't understand it sometimes i don't
understand
it doesn't make any sense well you know
what you that that desk lamp is on over
there in it
it's always been it's always it's on all
the time
check it out i got a new display back
there got the robot set up all my to
move the robots so you guys can see that
wait a minute how did you change that
were they on the one below it
no the robots were up there oh oh you
got those from up
okay yeah i wasn't i wasn't really
looking still got some up there but
i don't have room showing them [ __ ]
off
yeah you have i didn't realize i didn't
realize you had so many some of them are
models that i built some of them were
for made by a guy i know a friend of
mine
who lives in japan he's a french guy
lives in japan owns a company called hl
pro
who makes a lot of those he's a he's
president owner of [ __ ] hl pro and i
see that you put one next to baby yoda
that's right i'm sorry grogu
those are actually models yeah yeah i do
have both those and painted those
little girl goo yeah mazinger z if i
could get a robo g
i know that's not a good rubble jess
just get a robo get a robo one get her
one
yeah wait a 70 stuff yeah
i can't remember now the difference i
feel like i used to know the difference
between those two things
g was the improved version it came the
series that came out later remember he
had
the the the face that does this and the
three spikes come on out of the top oh
right right right okay
there was there was a time period when
we were like watching all the cartoons
and i had all the theme songs and [ __ ]
that i would listen to in the car and
whatnot
yeah and i could remember all the
distinctions but now like that was a
couple of years ago and i can't remember
they were the japanese version of like
uh comic book heroes
yeah go nagai wrote him yeah he was he
was kind of a fan of stan lee back in
the 70s
and they were superheroes but superhero
had to have a damn robot too just like i
said
even spider-man in japan had a robot
well i mean why wouldn't you have one
yeah when you think about it they
introduced spider-man and japan a
licensed
edition of [ __ ] spider-man you know
they're gonna make a movie
like it was a live-action movie and the
kids were like women
it's just a dude in a suit where's this
[ __ ] robot where's his robot
yes [ __ ] so in japan it was
it was kind of like it was kind of like
uh power rangers
you had the megazord yeah it was live
actually
you can't be a superhero without a mech
you had to have a mecca
so they made a damn big old [ __ ]
robot called leopoldeon
that he jumped in when he got in trouble
he jumped in that robot
i wish i had a robot that i could jump
into whenever i got into trouble
then i could just go and stomp on
whatever was causing the trouble
yeah no right there that was grinder
grandizer was
piloted by a guy named duke fleed duke
fleet was the japanese superman he was a
guy from another planet
sent to save earth basically that's
right i remember that character so
everything was very
super super manny yeah everything was
everything was a kind of a reboot of
something stan lee did or
you know what stan lee was doing in the
seven well actually stan lee did marvel
um
yeah so it was just something that was
like dc that was yeah it was it was a
reboot of something american
you know but putting their own like
they're like well that's cool but we
could make it like way way
yeah seriously all right so
obviously if you saw the title of this
we are finally getting around to doing
the casey anthony case tom said before
we started recording is like we should
probably be kind of diplomatic on this
show because she's probably watching it
yeah they live around here
yeah this happened right here in orlando
yeah we're not you know some shows have
really uh
beaten up on her and her family we're
not gonna do that we're just it's gonna
be a fair
show jenny just got done reading the
whole book about the case
and uh you've seen a couple programs on
it too right yeah yeah
yeah and actually what's funny is just
by pure coincidence
because like i said this is a local case
from where we are
dr matt who's a guy that i worked for i
worked i worked at
worked on his horses um his son
worked at the court at the courthouse
where this trial went down
and he told me days before the verdict
that they had no they had nothing on her
that she was
she was found not guilty well it's
interesting to me and i just told you
this that
you know from what i've read of the case
because i read a couple books on it and
i read
like i watched a bunch of different
documentaries on it and it's interesting
the way
the media kind of portrayed it which i
see which the media does a lot of
they just kind of simplify everything
because they're just trying to get
people to watch it and like some
most of the [ __ ] like any particularly a
murder trial like this was
um you're gonna get like all these
little subtle nuances and stuff like
that which doesn't really play
to you know the public so they try to
make everything really simple and like
try to sell a narrative and it's always
like the [ __ ] that was said on the stand
except for this case and like some of
the weird [ __ ]
that was going on with her family and
all this other kind of [ __ ] it's just
really kind of muddied the waters of
like what actually happened
and what the [ __ ] was actually going on
so i'm gonna say on the outset although
i don't think that she is blameless
obviously
um i do think that in this particular
case the jury
made the right decision in that i do not
think that it was premeditated murder
i'm gonna say that right there yeah
another case i was connected with is um
i worked for an attorney for a while
with her with some of her horses
and she handled the case of that kid
here from florida went to new orleans
and killed them people
killed that girl's family he got his
event
count visago i don't remember what his
real name was did we do a show on that
or no
i think we could i remember we did a
vampire killer show but we talked about
richard chase but i can't believe it i
can't remember
i remember what his name was he caught
himself count visago
and he was kind of role playing that he
was a vampire and maybe you guys might
remember who it was
yeah what the hell was that little
bitch's name yeah he wasn't little he
was kind of tall
yeah well yeah i just say little [ __ ]
too yeah
some weird [ __ ] i saw his original case
files she had the case file still before
she had the case over to another
to another attorney but she she
represented him for uh
probably about a year but then she had
it because there was extradition in
different states
involved so you know i mean she had to
hand the case over it was weird
how it was but yes i saw the case files
yeah
yeah so i also did some work in her
office [ __ ] doing some handyman stuff
and [ __ ] reorganizing all her files
and what the [ __ ] was his name
and i looked i knew that she was telling
me stories about him and i [ __ ]
i looked him up in her files as i was
moving and [ __ ] open that [ __ ] up and
looked at his [ __ ] case while i was
[ __ ] bizarre
yeah yeah weren't any photos but there
was descriptions and stuff what any
evidence really
yeah he's a dj maniac said i think you
cover him in the same episode as
chase yeah i think i think you did too
because i think we did a whole vampire
kiss yeah i don't remember that guy's
name episode
but i can't remember it offhand he's
evidently a legend man they still got a
girl sucking sending him letters
well that's true of any high profile
murderer
which is weird what does that say about
like a certain segment of the population
thought he was a vampire and was running
off of some young girl and
and her parents were [ __ ] with her
and wouldn't let it wouldn't let
wouldn't let them go to uh new orleans
where he could live out his vampire
fantasy
so he so he went to the house and
[ __ ] killed the parents and took the
girl
he was with a couple of his friends his
vampire minions
i don't remember what that fucker's name
was but he called himself count visago
said he was like a 300 year old vampire
i thought he was lestat
[Laughter]
i mean you know that's fine when you're
like 11 or 12 years old
but like once you kind of are out of the
tween years i think you need to
start but he was living it that
particular
dude was raised by a by by a golf
chick who was in her 30s i think
by this time maybe early 40s but she was
you know
she was like one of those kinds like
sonia who's constantly you know
picking up real young guys like 20 years
30 years younger than her you know yeah
and uh because they look hey if you can
still do it she could still do it
run through them young boys man
and uh his mom was kind of like that his
mom hung out with them
and was like sleeping with his friends
yeah that was like one of those kind of
deals that she was like just one of the
kids
i have to admit that that is pretty hard
because that would be like your dad
hanging out with the daughter's friends
sleeping with the daughter's friends and
that is equally creepy
well what's funny is that they ran
around town and [ __ ] and [ __ ] they
they
partied at their house at her house and
most people didn't know that that was
his mom
she looked the same age as the kids
right so they didn't know a lot of
people didn't know
yeah it was weird pretty weird there's
some weird-ass families going on out
there
which kind of ties into this whole casey
anthony thing because i'm going to say
right here
like she's got a lot of problems and her
parents are also
um they seem kind of bad [ __ ] crazy
that whole family seems magic the
brother seems okay maybe
but uh the rest of the family can
somebody look that case up for
somebody in the comments so i can look
that case up real quick get on my
[ __ ] vampire killer count visago
what's that dude's real name why can't i
think of it we probably like i said
we've done a whole show about it and we
talk about the case a lot because like
because it kind of happened i mean it
didn't happen here but like yeah yeah
candace represented her him yeah yeah
so you know that's kind of something
that's a little bit local
rob was it farrell
rob farrell rod farrell rod farrell
that's what it was rob farrell
yeah we did talk about him on that show
i'm pretty sure that kid
he's not a kid now well obviously none
of us are kids anymore
sanders says because somebody said joked
that they uh
wrote a love letter to chris watts that
murderer guy
um chris watts is disgusting but at the
same time
such an incredibly boring man he
definitely yeah he definitely was
yeah we saw it remember we saw that uh
documentary about it stop propagating
jumps and says rob farrell yeah you good
yeah dude we remembered it but thank you
you remembered it
i thought it was rob if rob something
but then she said pharaoh yeah rod
farrell
yeah yeah [ __ ] douchebag
victor said it wasn't a joke what did
you say in the love letter
the love letter to chris watts that's
[ __ ] up
oh did you see that somebody uh figured
out
the zodiac cipher that they hadn't been
able to figure out
what did it say nothing interesting
pretty much what
everybody was like hoping that it would
say hi i'm ted cruz
but no but no it doesn't say that it
just says pretty much
like what his other letters said
basically like
are you guys having a good time trying
to catch me i'm not afraid of the gas
chamber
um you know more slaves for paradise it
was just like more of the same
so it was just kind of like why couldn't
they solve it before um
but is it more difficult cipher it was a
more difficult cipher
and i think what um yeah there was like
one
there was an algorithm that this one guy
had figured out it was it was actually a
team of three guys it's like it was a
website designer and like
two other guys and they'd been working
on it for
a while they've been working out for
like years and they developed this
algorithm that
actually they just kept coming up with
like all this noise and [ __ ] and
then they saw the phrase gas
chamber in there so then they had to go
back and um
you know they they kind of kind of like
reverse engineer like oh if that's those
letters
and there were a few uh misspellings i
don't even know if it was misspellings
because
you know you know he zodiac did a lot of
misspellings but
i think that he messed up the code a
couple times which was throwing people
off
right you know what i mean like you used
the wrong symbol yeah yeah so i think
that was kind of causing some issues as
well
but um that apparently the fbi has come
out and said yeah but this is
this is it like um somebody did actually
solve it
this is the cipher the 340 cipher or
whatever it's called
it was the one because you you remember
we did a show about the zodiac that um
most of the other ciphers were solved
like almost immediately but for some
reason no one could crack this one for
like 50 years or however long it's been
but somebody finally figured it out and
like i said it was kind of anticlimactic
as i suspected it would be i think
everybody was just like
they were just so hoping that something
would come out of it because it took so
long to solve it's like oh
this must be some really valuable
information if he
went to all this trouble make this
really complicated code but
it was just the same kind of [ __ ] he
always said a lot of people here now
zach's here tila
bee's nest louise in
victor amanda sandra
everybody's here got about 50 in there
right now all right
yeah and i should say too that we went
over the 10
100 subscriber mark yeah that's right
yeah today
so yeah yeah hey t did you see um did
you see
um uh what was that [ __ ]
the one about the damn parasite from uh
uh [ __ ]
terrarium now what that was
did you see bavarium yet because i think
you said that was on the list
that was a [ __ ] good one man has
anybody made a horror movie called
terraria
that's like you know you make a little
terrain like a terrain but out of out of
lake
did you ever have to do that in school
where you made a terrarium out of like a
like an old
two-liter bottle like a plastic
two-liter bottle and like you had
you put all these little plants in there
and you had a little turtle in there and
[ __ ] like that
yeah i made that in school yeah that's
what that's whenever somebody says that
word that's the first thing i always
think of is my little terrarium that i
made with little turtles in it or frogs
or whatever i'm gonna try to um
get crunk
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sure you'll succeed man it's been
[ __ ] hard times man everybody's
having a hard times with all this
[ __ ]
i hadn't been feeling good in about
[ __ ] 18 months really man and
[ __ ] this shit's [ __ ] getting to me
it's getting to everybody
but uh i just can't wait for this [ __ ]
to be over with you just
you know what you have to do though it's
like and i i know this is like funny
coming for me because i'm like the
world's most stressed out and like
depressive person
ever but um in a lot of ways it's kind
of just helped me to just
not not not think about it but just give
a [ __ ] not give a [ __ ]
right you know what i mean i saw this
this book that came out that i think was
a bestseller that's called the subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ]
and i feel like you it's a
to a thing where you can't like just not
care about anything obviously you have
to care about [ __ ] but
i've tried nowadays like in the past
couple of years
i've kind of tried to come to a point
where i'm only gonna get
upset or care about [ __ ] that i can
directly do something about if it's like
too big for me to do anything about i
can't worry about it because i can't
what good is it gonna do
you know what i'm saying yeah so i have
to keep like telling myself that and i
think i finally got to like a zen point
where
i'm just kind of like well [ __ ] happens
nothing i i do is gonna like fix that or
prevent it or anything like that so i
just
like i was like never mind i'm just
gonna go watch some horror movies leave
me alone
i've been off all them damn performance
drugs for a couple weeks all my [ __ ]
hormones going back to normal i know
your hormones are just like going all
over my body dysmorphia is going back
down
i'm [ __ ] smaller my eyes are still a
little bit turning into like a crazy old
woman
i lost a lot of that water weight and my
waist went down my pants fit better
again
i got nuts again i can feel my nuts
don't hurt like they used to
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] killing me oh my
god we're only like 20 minutes in it
you're already talking about your nuts
my junk went back to normal that shit's
[ __ ]
like shriveling up like it's on a cold
day
that's artificial hormones are [ __ ] up
i'm getting the balance back getting the
balance back
i'm not working out as much only like
once a week now for per body part so
and we've been and we've been eating
less lately
like you know what i mean yeah trying to
like you made i have to say you made a
very very nice curry today like a
chicken curry
it turned out very very good tomorrow
i'm gonna hit it though man
yeah yeah i'm gonna hit i'm gonna hit
the gym tomorrow
and then uh it's just a constant [ __ ]
fighting off soreness man
but that that's what's keeping my my
mental state normal
no let's not keep my mental state normal
when the hell is your mental state ever
been normal
no your mentality has never been normal
trying to return to normal
um that [ __ ] lgd man if it's called
legandrol that legandro
man when it's it [ __ ] up a man's
hormone system it makes you feel like
you're [ __ ] cross between
getting ready to impregnate something or
be or you're pregnant at the same time
it's going to come from yeah it's like a
goddamn alien
swell up for a while you have like
increased libido and then that [ __ ] goes
away
and then it pops out of your chest and
everyone goes
yeah all your [ __ ] body parts are the
wrong size
your eyes [ __ ] get small yeah he
keeps saying my eyes are small
there's no way to describe it it's just
a sensation
that your eyes get small and then you
feel like your [ __ ]
belly is sticking out about [ __ ] you
feel like you you feel like the [ __ ]
egg man
you feel like hey dude yeah dude
i've been having periods since i was 12.
i know that feeling
yeah he's like my why won't my feet fit
in my shoes
and then your upper body [ __ ] feels
all [ __ ] swollen and [ __ ] and then
it's just uh you but you see that's not
the end result you know i'm trying to
explain to people
you're just trying to increase the the
speed of the healing really that's how
you do it
you can heal real fast but you're you're
pregnant it's like you've been pregnant
by aliens
well that could happen it's a
possibility they came and impregnated
you in your sleep
your androgens all get [ __ ] up you're
[ __ ] not not producing testosterone
babies you just [ __ ] you and then you
sweat start smelling like plastic
like burning plastic i did notice that
yeah yeah so it smells like [ __ ]
plastic it's starting to go back to
normal though we should have some
you should have some alien babies they
can play with spooky man
maybe they'll look like maybe they'll
look like baby yoda i'm done with that
[ __ ] for a while
zach and tammy both said uh that this
show has really helped them get through
like and cheer them up like during these
hard times
i don't know how man because this shit's
starting to get to me man the past month
it's been [ __ ] building up on me man
i just look at what's happening i look
at the real news the fake news
the [ __ ] conspiracy news and just
videos of what's happening
and i don't like none of this [ __ ] man i
don't like none of this [ __ ]
i'm not about this i don't i i i do kind
of [ __ ]
i do kind of sometimes embracing chaos
and just seeing what
like yeah this is totally different but
uh this shit's going on for a long time
you know i'm talking about this is going
on for two life goes on for a long time
and i just and it's not just me you know
i mean some of you guys contact me you
know
in private you know we'll chat i just
gotta uh i just got a feeling that this
is not going anywhere good
uh there's certain [ __ ] i can't we
can't talk about everything it's not
kind of political show
but if you if you all are feeling like
you're crazy you're not crazy this [ __ ]
the world is [ __ ] going crazy
and um there's a certain pattern to all
this
there's guys like me that break [ __ ] for
a living and
break things and places for a living and
this shit's breaking
but it can also be fixed it's just it's
not it's not gonna
i think it might go to a dark place it
just depends on how dark
and for how long yeah but then you don't
know that
like i said there's too many factors and
it's just like that's the that's the
pattern
right but i'm just like reading tea
leaves and fortunes and [ __ ]
in some way in horoscopes it may be but
it's not right like i said me worrying
about it isn't going to have an effect
one way or the other
so you can only cover your own ass and
look out for [ __ ] that's happening in
here's something i constantly tell
myself and i want to tell you people
this all right first of all
or steel is forged on the anvil of
chrome you are heated
and then you are beaten and then you are
heated and then you are beaten
and then eventually you are quenched
okay that's what happens to you we are
all
on the anvil of crom all right this is
beating out impurities in all of us some
will fall
by the wayside okay that's that's the
way
this [ __ ] really is all right i lost
where i track where i was
where where the [ __ ] was i looking at
all man i remember you know what is very
funny i keep thinking of this and i know
it was kind of meant as a joke but
this is something that i think of often
it was you know where i got it from the
mystery science theater
uh episode guide of all places and i
think it was paul chaplin that wrote
that his philosophy of life was
you know probably everything's gonna be
okay and even if it's not
if you wait long enough eventually it
will be yeah
there are no permanent states of being
well that's what i'm saying
everything is temporary so you just kind
of have to roll
with it just roll with it be like water
like bruce lee says
yeah yeah you might die but you know
after that's over you won't care well
see that's how i look at it like i'm not
like hoping i die or anything like that
but i'm just saying well
after i'm dead i won't give a [ __ ]
anymore so yeah i just don't like being
in a situation where you can't directly
control it yourself and that's what i'm
telling
to tell a lot of people you could
everything that you the only things you
can do now are very local
you watch out for your own [ __ ] your own
people and in your
localized area and everybody's going to
be in a different situation
it doesn't matter what country you're in
too because each country is this is
global
it's not just here it's everywhere
everywhere in the
western world right now it's kind of
[ __ ] up
and you can only do what you can do and
i kind of kee i have to keep reminding
myself
that when you see these videos of things
happening in other places and
read news news has always been fake it
goes back to
the yellow journalism it's always to try
it's like agit prop which is
well it's just they're just trying to
get you to watch it yeah it's click
and they also want to make you mad and
manipulate you yeah because that gets
you to watch it gets you a lot to watch
it or it gets you to [ __ ]
vote for this or that or send money to
this or something
so it's called because i'm like i see
what you're doing yeah in the military
it's called
agit prop which means agitation
propaganda all right it is
news and the things that you see
remotely on the internet
videos of what's happening in other
places you're taking the world's
problems and you're bringing them to
your front door
that's not happening to you most likely
well i think that
we live a person we live a good peaceful
life but i'm still
[ __ ] and it's [ __ ] with me well see
but that's i think that's why
so many people even though you know
there's less crime now than there used
to be in a lot of ways like things are a
lot better than they used to be
um because i've read like tons and tons
of like essays and books and [ __ ]
about this it's not so much that there's
more
bad stuff that's happening it's the same
or less as before but it's like before
you didn't know about it you we didn't
have the internet you didn't know about
[ __ ] that was going on
you know in like some distant city you
don't know about that stuff but now you
do
and it seems like it's this big
overwhelming you know kind of [ __ ]
because you just seem like this one
little tiny person it's like oh my god
all of this [ __ ] is happening but all of
that [ __ ] has always been happening it's
always been happening you just didn't
know a lot of the bad [ __ ] you're seeing
is not even happening in your state
that's what i'm saying a lot of it's
just far away no but but when people see
things and
it's an evolutionary thing like how our
brains obviously like adapted to
be very very receptive to negative
stimuli but you know because it keeps
your ass like back on the savannah or
whatever it kept your ass from getting
killed
but nowadays you're seeing [ __ ] that's
not even remotely
it doesn't directly involve you but it
still feels like it does
because you're seeing it you know in
front of your face like
you know on your tv or your on the
internet or whatever
so you feel like it's happening right in
front of you even though it might be
happening like somewhere far away
i'm not saying that you know it's good
like all this [ __ ] that has like murders
and wars and [ __ ] like that
obviously that's bad but i'm just saying
that it's not happening any more
frequently or any worse or anything than
it
used to be happening it's just that you
hear so much more about it nowadays
and it's just in your face 24 7 and you
can't get away from it
so i can see why people are getting
overwhelmed so like i said i try to
maintain some perspective
um and weirdly it helps to see things
like you remember when we watched that
documentary
uh about the one that had been colorized
i think peter jackson did it like about
world war one
where they colorized like all that
footage from world war one and
like that seeing [ __ ] like that
as horrifying and depressing as it was
it made me feel a lot better because i'm
like look at those people lived
through that that happened to them they
were there they saw all that stuff
and they were all right afterward
like they had like an okay life you know
what i mean like [ __ ] got back to normal
eventually
so [ __ ] like that and that was like a
catastrophic
you know kind of thing so i always kind
of feel like humans are very adaptable
you know
bad [ __ ] can happen bad [ __ ] is always
happening but eventually
[ __ ] will hit some kind of equilibrium
because that's just what
happens that's just what happened
they're going to get sick of this [ __ ]
eventually
and then and then the rich people are
going to start losing money when they
start losing money all this [ __ ] will
stop
but uh yeah people are agreeing with me
and they're going on
and uh tila told you to take a picture
of me
transforming i don't really know exactly
what you're transforming into
like from the smaller thing to the
bigger things into humpty dumpty
or into the hulk because i'm small right
now i can [ __ ] transform you know in
about three weeks of taking that [ __ ]
i'll be blown up like the [ __ ] humpty
dumpty
so i'm not really sure although a lot of
that is like
i've changed a lot in two years i think
you have yeah but sometimes when you sit
there and say
like oh today you feel like the michelin
man or whatever but it's like you don't
look that much different
i feel like i'm [ __ ] fat but see i
know what you're talking about because
like i said i've had periods since i was
12. so it's like and it's a very
similar like you feel like even though
you maybe look a little chunkier or a
little more
because you say sometimes you look a
little bit bloated today or you know
what i mean
but you feel like you're like this big
around
yeah like oh my god none of my clothes
oh yeah right your clothes don't feel
like they fit right you know and it's
like and
when i walk i feel like i'm like
waddling or sloshing and
stuff like that it's like i know that
that's yeah objectively not what i'm
doing but that's what it feels like i
was just taking that [ __ ] to get over a
couple little [ __ ]
humps every now and every now and then
you'll get kind of stuck in your
progress
because you're working out too much you
got to heal up faster at a faster rate
so you you'll get on that [ __ ] for about
a month
i i was taking something called
legandrol which
it's not a steroid but it's it's it's
it's a selective androgen receptor
modulator it was something that
athletes were taking to try to get
around [ __ ] steroid tests
it makes you strong yeah because there's
always some kind of loop yeah there's
some kind of loophole
it's it's it's like a damn hologram of a
steroid you think your body thinks you
took it but you didn't
it's a trick it's not as good as steroid
steroids are [ __ ]
really good but you can buy them over
the counter as research chemicals
you can get them they have now they have
it and you had athletes that were using
it
but now they have a test to test for it
now so it's not quite as
popular as it used to be but
man they'll double your heal your speed
of healing they'll double it
yeah yeah but something like
anavar anavar [ __ ] quadruple your
speed
healing and it feels good it feels a lot
better
because it's like a bit it's like a
synthetic testosterone
take that [ __ ] it's just super solder
serum you're just like oh yeah i'm a man
i'm gonna
[Laughter]
but that only lasts a little while then
well it depends some of them guys are
also
[ __ ] taking injections of
testosterone on top of that
there's side effects to all that [ __ ]
don't take don't take i'm telling you
don't take it
i'm telling the audience don't take any
of that [ __ ] there's side effects yeah
you look at their pro bodybuilders man
they're abusing that [ __ ] a lot of them
[ __ ] especially from the early age
they didn't live very long
they were maxing out on that [ __ ] when
they were real young
and by the time they were in their 50s
they were burned out they were [ __ ] up
their livers were [ __ ] [ __ ] too
and um their dollar joints because they
were just lifting too much goddamn
weight
all right that's not what steroids were
for
the steroids were just to [ __ ]
increase speed of healing if you had
injury
all right now some people could took
them there's
been you know guys like jacqueline lane
if you guys know who jacqueline elaine
jacqueline lane lived like 96 97 yeah he
was in his 90s and he looked great all
the way to that and that's because he
was mostly natural until he got into his
50s and he
he took that [ __ ] at therapeutic doses
just to kind of like almost kind of like
testosterone replacement therapy
and that's actually life extension it's
just
you got to have ways to get your hands
on it that [ __ ] should all be legal i i
am totally
against all this drug prohibition
yeah i mean you should be able to have
to a certain extent
i think that you should be as long as um
the companies that make the [ __ ] are
honest about what the side effects are
yeah um then i don't have a problem with
people being like yeah i'm all right
with that or
you know if that happens i mean as long
as you can make an informed decision
i don't like the whole thing where you
can just put out drugs like on the down
low and like
you know you can kind of lie about what
they do or where
you don't lie about what's in it and
[ __ ] like that because i think that's
kind of what happens with a lot of
like vitamin supplements and things like
that because of the way they're
regulated
they don't really have to disclose if it
has
like i can't remember what exactly what
the law is but it if it has like what
it's supposed to
have or you can make like certain claims
about it but as long as you word it a
certain way
then you won't get sued and all this
other kind of [ __ ] there's all these
like work arounds
so i don't like that um like i said be
honest about what the [ __ ] does just
like drug companies have to be
you know at the end of every drug
commercial now they have to say you know
may cause this that the other thing
that's good you know they should do that
for everything so everybody
knows what they're getting into that's
all i'm just saying you should be able
to take whatever you want as long as
you're you know of age and everything as
long as you know what you're getting
into
we got 62 in the chat now we're going to
start the show here in just a minute
sandra has asked me tommy did you know
that steven seagal sings
you see they're trying to [ __ ] get me
and trying to yeah he did the punani
song we talked about that i mean he's
done more songs than that but that was
the one that just stuck in my mind i
can't imagine segal sings about punani
all right i was watching the other day
i might have to do a [ __ ] video
review of this all right
see jenny and i were considering maybe
like opening up another little channel
like coming here and like doing a series
do a whole series of just reviews [ __ ]
although that's mostly going to be on
you because i'd probably fall asleep
watching those
you got you guys seem to like me [ __ ]
with cigar
[Laughter]
i was watching the steven seagal
documentary that he put out
that was showcasing his history who he
was where he was born
his prowess as a demon was that the one
that you were showing me part of
yeah it's like an infomercial it was
exactly the way i imagined it yeah it's
like
information from like the mid-90s
of of you know come study with [ __ ]
master [ __ ]
master [ __ ] seagal you know since
this sensei
and man this [ __ ] here man it had
a soundtrack at the back that was
stereotypical eastern spiritual [ __ ]
sound
you know like [ __ ] units like he
downloaded that [ __ ] from like
freesound.org
well not back in the 90s back in the 90s
like you couldn't download [ __ ]
but oh yeah though yeah it was a long
time ago this is like something off a
vhs tape it reminded me of [ __ ]
on um uh that movie that we saw
[ __ ] artist self defense if you have
the blu-ray there's a special
[ __ ] section of the blu-ray where you
can go in there and see the commercial
that sensei put out to get you to come
to his dojo it's [ __ ] hilarious
uh was tila you didn't get to see that
that that but on the blu-ray
there's a commercial for that dojo and
[ __ ]
all the [ __ ] that [ __ ] sensei says
anyway that's the way
this steven seagal it was about 45
minutes
of of jerking off steven seagal that's
basically what we're doing
about how [ __ ] awesome this dude is
yeah and that's exactly what i would
have expected that's all it is
it's just a constant like models and
like
d-list actors and then some dudes from
dojos
every time it's just a clip of four or
five seconds telling you how awesome
[ __ ] steve is the gospel
he's the best person from him i learned
you know the secrets of
this and that oh and master and then and
in the beginning it's
talking about his uh showing photos of
his early master and it's
straight out of like a [ __ ] chinese
kung fu flick an old japanese dude with
a long
[ __ ] white beard you know the long
way here that was that's who he learned
the magical age and all that shit's been
debunked
well he's not there at that time and no
he during the time that that guy was
alive
seagal would have been like six or
something you know yeah we talked about
that on the stephen seagal show it's
like
he did live in japan for a while because
wasn't he married to like a japanese
woman i'm forgetting like a lot of the
facts now but
the the [ __ ] that he said about studying
under this master of that matter
was he showed pictures of him
exaggerated let's put it that way and
then like him doing [ __ ] aikido out
in the field with his students
if you look at it from today's
standpoint it's just him out in a park
with some people and they filmed that
[ __ ] back in the 90s everyone was like
oh so that was
wow yeah but um they felt like and i was
[ __ ]
yeah i was tripping i was tripping
through the whole thing i was
i was trying to learn something and
really all i did was just a constant
barrage of how awesome [ __ ] steven
seagal was
and he really didn't learn much just how
awesome he was
well he learned that because i saw
master cigar i saw sensational fly
through a [ __ ] plate glass [ __ ]
window didn't even get cut he's an
incredible man
okay steven seagal invented the cure for
cancer then like this pretty blonde
woman
you know since they said
sensei taught me how this and that he he
is sensei is the ultimate heterosexual
you know just some [ __ ] like that you
know
please tell me she really said that i
know she didn't know i was just
but yeah i was [ __ ] i was trying
steven seagal
yeah i will get i will give and it's on
youtube you guys can see it just look up
steven seagal
training documentary it will come up
fourth drawer down says seagal will fly
down to florida on a cloud and be back
before he left
but i will say this [ __ ]
most people today will goof on cigar
because he's got a big [ __ ] donut
mustache and he's [ __ ] this big
[ __ ] heavyset dude
with the [ __ ] ponytail and
but that's not the way he was when he's
young if you see pictures of him when he
was young
you know i mean in his 30s and 20s and
30s you see where the legend came from
he was
in his youth in really good shape he was
a handsome guy
he was very handsome that's what i'm
saying it's like it's not like he's just
some weird complete loser like that
like that creepy weirdo that made like
all those videos back in the 80s what
the [ __ ] was that dude's name
oh uh akita shim yeah yeah yeah you know
he was a kid
yeah he wasn't like a complete no she
loser like that dude
that was just like making everything up
it was like look i'm teaching you ninja
skills by like having these old 80s vhs
types of me sneaking around someone's
you know [ __ ] house in the [ __ ]
suburbs but it's like
steven seagal did have actually have
some talent in that regard
but then the fact that he just blows
himself up into this completely
unrealistic
yeah it's like you should have just been
happy with what you had
instead of trying to like blow yourself
up into something that you weren't but
the problem with seagal is that by the
time he was famous he was already in
round 35 and uh he had already kind of
puffed himself up into something that he
wasn't
yeah and in order to defend this image
he had to continue to pile on lies
he was insecure about yeah he was
because
he's competing against chuck norris he's
competing against all these other guys
who are real martial
van damme who are in excellent [ __ ]
condition
and really i will give van damme that he
actually was really i don't know about
nowadays but he actually really wasn't
no he's actually
still pretty good okay well i haven't
seen him a long time so i don't know
yeah he's got a bad cocaine problem but
he's
for you know maybe that's why he didn't
get fat yeah
i mean you know but um cocaine does
actually keep you slim there's a lot of
downsides he's off of it he was actually
pretty intelligent
uh just he had a drug problem yeah he
always struck me as like a pretty
like with it tonight by the time he was
well known he was already
kind of kind of over the hill he was a
little bit over the head
as far as movies and [ __ ] go no he was
over the hill kind of physically
his conditioning was actually declining
he was more of a movie star and an
actor than he was an athlete or a
fighter he didn't he wasn't a guy who
went to a ring and fought right this is
just a keto yeah it's like tai chi
you know what i mean you can do some
fighting [ __ ] but if you went to cigar
says what
name a fight you were in you know what i
mean oh i fought f but
there's no videos of him fighting not
real fights you know
he didn't go he didn't go to [ __ ] ufc
ultimate fighting [ __ ] challenger you
know he didn't do
it was he was an actor that's that's
what he really was he was an actor that
had some martial arts training yeah
that's what he was
uh but like i said the other guys were
martial arts guys that have some action
training
but they were they actually did fight
some of those guys
you know like chuck norris could whip
your ass he could fight
in his in his in his prime yeah like
nowadays but not so much because he's
old now but
yeah but um but yeah that's just
i don't know although chuck norris
wasn't really that great it was not
that great an actor he was a terrible
actor actually but um
he was actually a good martial artist i
will give him that yeah um
bruce lee said he was great yeah but
that's another thing bruce lee was also
an actor
he could he could fight but he didn't do
pro fights you know
he was in he was in amazing shape though
yeah bruce lee could not afford to fight
because he had to make movies
yeah if he got hurt that would cost him
[ __ ] a [ __ ] ton of money because he
wouldn't be able to [ __ ]
work right because they're like what is
all this yeah so it wasn't really worth
it we don't have enough makeup to come
around but if you see that
[ __ ] uh movie uh once upon a time in
hollywood
where the the stuntman throws bruce lee
into a car that's actually kind of based
on something that really did happen
there was a stunt man who was friends
with bruce and bruce and they were
[ __ ] around
and he went behind bruce when i just
picked him up off the ground
and uh you can
you can punch pretty hard you can kick
pretty hard but as soon as somebody can
just pick you up off the ground you
can't get enough leverage to really hurt
that person
yeah i mean because the thing like size
difference matters yeah the thing about
it is that bruce lee was in amazing
shape but he was a small yeah
like he wasn't that heavy he was
probably about five four weighed about a
hundred so sometimes
just being big even if you're not real
conditioned or anything like that can be
an advantage
he only weighed about 145 pounds yeah he
was like
he but he was fast yeah and he had real
good reflexes and he could hit you
several times
before you could really do much about it
but like i said he was not a fighter
now could you take bruce lee and turn
him into uh
uh you know a cage or what do they call
him [ __ ] mixed martial mma
you could train him for mma he'd
probably do well on mma yeah i think he
would but he'd have to put on about 20
pounds but he'd do it he
yeah he tried i think he could do it
yeah he probably 20 30 pounds and he'd
be he'd have been a badass he was
training for a type of combat that
doesn't exist anymore
yeah you know that's all mma now
yeah but many people who knew him back
in the day said that he would have done
great in mma
i think from what i know about him i
think that is the case yeah yeah
okay so now we have uh
tila was that tilas was saying that she
never saw a mystery science theater
because i mentioned it a long time ago
before we went off on this whole steven
seagal thing
you got to be a [ __ ] nerd to
understand
yeah it's i hesitate like i love mystery
science theater
more than almost anything in my life
except for him and pokey
but um it's
an acquired taste like you either love
it
or you don't get it i don't get most of
the humor because you have to have read
a lot of books and seen a lot of movies
and a lot of like really obscure media
like weird commercials from 70s
if you wanted to an introduction to to
mst
watch the mst the newer series that's on
netflix
which i actually didn't mind like a lot
of um old school mst
fans did not like it i liked it but it's
different
like all the voices are different they
did it a little bit different but
i actually liked it it's its own thing
it has fake commercial breaks just like
the original just like the old ones
there's no commercial but it acts like
it's going to go to a commercial little
dancing skeleton guys and that's that's
from a [ __ ]
what was the name of that yeah that was
from that weird mega man
but there's just if you've seen a lot of
shitty movies you'll understand it but
it had a nice upbeat tone to it and i
was very happy watching
the new mst it makes you very happy
watching it
it's just a good i honestly i've seen
all
like because i i'm a super super fan so
i've seen like every episode of the
original series
um probably 20 times each um so i could
probably i don't know if i could recite
them because there's so many jokes per
episode that you can never remember them
all so i'm always like discovering like
a new one because like oh i just i
didn't remember that or i didn't hear it
or i
understand it the first time but um i
used to just like put them on
in my house like a long time ago when i
was like you know doing housework or
whatever i would just put them on in the
background
because there's something really like
comforting about them um i will say that
i really really like there's also
like it kind of split off in two
directions like after they have the new
one that's on netflix which is all
pretty much new people like that's joel
who was the original host is behind that
and then you have riff tracks
which is mike kevin bill who are on like
the sci-fi
era um and that's also really good they
it's because it's very much like the
sci-fi era
uh mst but it doesn't have host segments
it doesn't have the silhouettes it
doesn't have anything like that but it
has
the three of them you know that's the
voices that you got used to like during
the sci-fi era because
you know mike is mike and then kevin did
servo and bill did
crow during that time period so you're
seeing the same three guys like riffing
on movies
and uh if you want 2b has like a [ __ ]
ton of rifftrax episodes um
you know for free that you can watch
there's commercials in them but it's not
that big a deal
so if you kind of want to like dip your
foot in the well or whatever
those are really good and they have some
of their live shows on there too
and uh joel and mary jo
and some of the other people on frank
and some of the other people trace
they did uh cinematic titanic which is
also funny
so all of them are still like doing [ __ ]
you know what i mean
um other than like the netflix series
that they did which like i said a lot of
old school mst people didn't like it
because the riffing style was different
it was like much quicker
there was a lot of like more recent
uh references and [ __ ] like that but i
actually uh surprised myself by liking
it
quite a bit yeah t there's a commercial
for sensei on [ __ ] the
you could probably see that on youtube
they may have uploaded the commercial
from um from from sensei
that shit's [ __ ] you after you see
the movie and you see the commercial
you'll [ __ ] laugh your ass off
okay told me count down business said
count dante
train seagal i'm laughing actually count
dante was actually
i kind of respected count dante because
that [ __ ] was a lunatic
and he really was fighting um
michael schaefer says that sheet of kim
was one of my favorite grift acts
yeah yeah i think what the [ __ ] is
she
he got away with it you gotta respect
that too we'll go ahead and talk about a
kishida kim real quick before we start
the show
kim wasn't grifting he believed that
[ __ ]
all right he was it was a grip from our
point of view from our point of view
it was it was a gift but from his point
of view
he was he actually believed he was a
ninja and that he was doing all this
[ __ ]
he really did seem to buy into his own
yeah but but
it this is co there was no concept of
larping
back in those days but that's what it
was it was live action role play
in a way he was fantasizing that he was
a ninja master
and living at that living that fantasy
out
and recording it and selling that those
vhs tapes to kids basically yeah you
would have to be i
had to be kids or people that are
mentally had mental problems
and all those tapes are available on
youtube yeah you can watch all of them
there
yeah still like they're hilarious
they're delightful and
i watched all of them like before we did
our [ __ ] they were all recorded with
something like maybe like a little
samsung [ __ ] video yeah
camcorder that would [ __ ] that
appeared and they were only 300 bucks
which was cheap as [ __ ] for
i think that's how much ours was i
bought one yeah my dad had one but he
bought it used and i think it was
250 or 300 or something like that and it
was that image
it had a whole video you could put the
whole vhs in it yeah and
the image quality wasn't good uh
but that's what that was filmed with on
a tripod
and he's doing these demonstrations of
him dodging bullets
which is just him doing this and they
added bullet sound effects
well yeah it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
bizarre
and he would bullets left to the
viewer's imagination yeah
a little asterisk him creeping around
outside in broad daylight going [ __ ]
getting low underneath his windows
his ninja skills on how to break into
somebody's
that was the part that cracked me up
yeah and he's you break it into his own
house
yeah and it's just like there's
absolutely obviously
and there's absolutely nothing to learn
from the video nothing
nothing that's all something that you
would know you would you would
automatically know that if you don't
want to be seen duck underneath the
window
you know what i mean of course you know
oh i never would have thought of that
[ __ ] genius and then he's to walk
silently you tiptoe well
don't you tiptoe you know also probably
want to take off your shoes
right so there's like so some kid paid
40 bucks for this training
through a vhs tape and maybe if you're
[ __ ] 10 11 12 you would really think
you
saw some [ __ ] cool yeah they would
put their little black pajamas on and
they'd be like sneaking around the house
pretending they were in ninjas yeah you
show that [ __ ] to a kid today
like just look at the comments looking
underneath the damn video on youtube you
should do a [ __ ]
a kid today wouldn't even know what it
was he was watching yeah
i think it's so far removed so far
removed from modern culture like is this
a joke
you're like what is a you know what even
a child would know that was a joke
nowadays
what is a this is martial artist what is
a martial art
yeah i don't know i just feel like
everything yeah
is that dude yeah he's still around he's
still around he's still around and he's
trying to put on the put on the face
that yeah that he's actually a ninja
bastard
didn't he do that
yeah that he was floating he was
levitating another one is he was proven
to people who didn't believe him that he
was a ninja he said all ninjas
have a secret invisible tattoo
of a some other ninja clan and is he
trolling
no he's [ __ ] serious and and i mean
and then he takes so to prove that he's
a ninja
and he's doing this in front of this
damn video camera he takes some ashes
and sprinkles it on his forearm and and
the [ __ ]
oriental writing appears well he just
put wax on his [ __ ] hand
on his [ __ ] just put clear wax on his
[ __ ]
obviously probably or something sticky
yeah deodorant would work and then
sprinkled it on there
anything that would like have some
adherence yeah now that now that i've
proven to you that i have an invisible
tattoo
[Laughter]
and like his his assistant is a [ __ ]
a disabled guy who can barely stand up
his [ __ ] legs are
or deformed and they're doing karate
together and he's propped up against a
wall doing the karate with him yeah
that's his that's his main assistant so
it's just two dudes
with a video camera and a kung fu
fantasy
and i'd imagine [ __ ] the sheet of kim
baited this
he baited this handicapped dude into
this [ __ ] deal
i'll turn you into a ninja master yeah
they were just like hey they're just
like friends they met at the lab
the library or the subway or something
one day
and he's like hey i make these like you
know videos it's pretty sad man
it is i mean at least they're like
entertaining themselves
i don't want to [ __ ] on them too hard
it's like you know
i'm a dork i'm so you know i i i have a
natural
instinct to like sympathize with other
dorks
but there comes a point where come on
man
come on like the in the invisible tattoo
thing was just like two [ __ ] watch
like even a five-year-old child nowadays
would be like [ __ ]
that's okay you are ready to start the
show let's start well i haven't even
done the shout outs
okay let's do the shout outs then holy
crap you've been we're an hour
well i wonder whose fault that could be
i don't know well they're asking for
crazy questions all right so
this week we have two new patrons
i think i saw one of them in the
comments earlier uh we have a new patron
named timothy
so hi there i think you're in the
comments hello and also one named saul
i also have to give another shout out to
the same timothy because he also not
only did he become a patron
but he also sent me a paypal donation on
top of all that so thank you very much
that's really really awesome
also this is hilarious okay so
michael e who has sent us many things
before
sent us this package the other day and i
legit laughed my ass off when i opened
this package
yeah can we can we just show it's still
got i i left [ __ ]
on my first name okay so he sent us
he sent us this right here yeah like the
death wish
that's a [ __ ] that's a steel book too
it is it's still looking delicious
okay now this one was on the top and
this is what made me laugh you got
underneath the bottom he gave me that
growth
[Laughter]
and this movie is called pain and gain
which actually i don't think i've ever
heard i've ever heard of it no
but yeah it's like just it looks pretty
good it's like you know
dwayne johnson's in it you love him mark
wahlberg is in it
yeah like i said i love from boogie
nights uh also i got this blu-ray i
i remember somebody messaging me about
this like a while back but i can't
remember who it was so it's like please
like forgive me
but this is like the first season
of true detective so thank you very much
for sending me that because this is a
show that i've kind of been wanting to
get into and i have never
watched it so i will be watching that
sometime in the next few weeks
are we ready to get into the case well
our drinks are empty now oh here let me
make another drink so
so maybe you should go and i'll start
talking about [ __ ]
go ahead and do it i'll just get you
casey anthony like i said maybe by this
point because we're already an hour in
she got bored and
left last i heard i don't know if this
is still the case or not
and as i said i don't want anybody to
think that i'm defending
casey anthony like particularly because
i don't think she's like the world's
greatest person obviously
um but i mean there are some
there is some [ __ ] that i'll get into
and like i said i don't think that she
killed
the baby on purpose um
but the [ __ ] that she did afterward was
just like unforgivable
but the last thing that i heard about
was that
she was doing a movie
like about she wasn't supposed to be in
it or anything but they were making i
don't know if it was a lifetime movie or
if it was supposed to be like
theatrical or i don't know what it was
but she was supposed to be making a
movie about like her side of the story
i don't remember what it was called but
it was supposed to be
the weird thing about it was that they
kind of made a big deal about it
having being like sexy which ew
you know you are famous because or
infamous i should say
you know because you
because your baby died and you like
covered up to death oh did you tell them
about that so
that cookbook oh no i didn't okay
why you want to say that cookbook's
coming along come along good it looks
really good and we're
it'll be it'll be done in a few about a
month or so bro yeah i
was trying to get it done by christmas
which i still might but i don't know it
might just be a little bit after
christmas but maybe by new year
just because i'm what we've been doing
like i said is i have the the layout's
finished like it's all the pages are
laid out and everything like that it
just has like dummy text in it
and then he's been coming in in town and
being like okay well
this needs to say this and that the
other so i'm like typing everything up
and like putting it where it's supposed
to go
and um a lot of big that that southern
section is going to be good
i think so yeah that's the one we've
been working on yeah a lot of soul food
and [ __ ]
yeah you guys are like yeah [ __ ] that my
grandmother used to make
yeah it's actually it's not verbatim her
recipes but close
close yeah great yeah it'll be good yeah
yeah
i mean i'm i'm really trying like i said
i i made a
deadline for myself that i was going to
get it done by christmas but then i was
like well
if i can't get it done by christmas i
don't want to beat myself up too much
because
i want it to be really good yeah so it's
i don't want to rush it
[ __ ] we forgot to put collard greens in
there
i can put that in there okay i can still
i can put pages in anytime you want
okay we just thought too that in our
dessert section
you said oh we need to put i'll put your
aunt's
uh chocolate and claire recipe whatever
happened to that video that that really
long video that i made of you it's like
a few years ago i got that we got those
eclairs on video though
gigantic hamburgers man it's hilarious i
think i still have it somewhere
it's like an hour long maybe or 45
minutes or something like that
and that recipe's from like the 30s
where you were making them man they were
good
but they're they're like these they're
eclairs but they're like these big
they're huge chocolate claire's filled
with custard
and they're rounds they're round they're
like bigger than they're like
these masks like the size of a whopper
bigger
it looks like okay you know you know
that sport curling
it looks kind of like that thing that
they use when they're curling
it reminds me of that for some reason
it's not quite that big but it's like
getting there
yeah so yeah victor says i hope you all
put turkey next in the book oh we should
we have like we have a whole
thanksgiving section like for people
that are in other countries and don't
like no
and plus you have you know recipes that
we
do on our thanksgiving like brazilian
cream corn and stuff like that that
maybe normal people don't make yeah or
maybe people in the u.s don't make
but uh yeah i'd have to call my dad and
ask him about that turkey neck recipe
that was that you should that was that
was the uh the people live across the
street
the black woman lives across the street
gives them the turkey next that's her
recipe fourth certainly the best turkey
necks he's ever had
how many turkey necklaces in the
mississippi man it's mississippi black
people
[ __ ] talking about well like i said
taking
yeah to me like taking cheap ingredients
and making them delicious
is like a way is way more like a sign of
a good cook than somebody
that can take really good [ __ ] and make
it taste good like yeah it already
tastes good
take some like shitty like yeah cheap
[ __ ] and make that taste good heidelberg
mississippi population 600. all right my
dad's the last white guy
everybody else is black they take care
of him man the old guy they're the ones
that called the hot
called the ambulance on him when he was
out in front dying they were [ __ ]
visiting him in the hospital he's
[ __ ] healthy that's why yeah he had
to get a bypass like i said
if you guys were here like he had to get
a dude lives across the street from him
is the mayor it was the mayor's wife
the mayor is he was a an army captain
but he's now a national mississippi
national guard colonel
okay who lives across from my dad being
in the navy and service guys watching
out for each other
they were the ones that found him dying
out on the [ __ ] front of stoop
but they were the ones who were bringing
him to turkey next his wife was
and he thought that the doctor put
turkey necks in him when it fixed him
look we're getting off track so he's
going to turn the [ __ ] track
fourth order will there be a drink with
that recipe well there'll be a drink
section there is a small drink section
we put drinks and desserts at the end
yeah like we'll have you know the lord
kukulkan
like some of the [ __ ] we drink on the
show and like [ __ ] like mojitos and
stuff like that
there's a few drinks in there that uh
that we do
um all right so like i said we're
talking about the casey anthony case
so saying these are people who eat
chicken feet and [ __ ] yeah they'll eat
anything
well like i said if you can like make
that good they go down to griers
which is a whole [ __ ] southern
grocery store but and they'll get
ham hocks and [ __ ] hog jaws
[ __ ] like that they're the cheapest cuts
of meat but they can flip that around
and turn it into something called ramsay
would be
would serve which like i said that's a
lot more impressive you have to know how
to
how to cook those cuts it's easy to take
[ __ ] top of the shelf pork tenderloin
and make that good that's what i'm
saying because that's good just like
right out of the box right you know but
you get you buy a lot of stuff that
really
isn't nobody wants it and you turn that
into a meal that's just like man it's
like a delicacy
yeah so that's why i kind of like we i
think we haven't really been keeping up
with gordon ramsay's latest series like
we watched it for a while and then i
forgot about it but
yeah he kind of goes to these places
where you know he went to like
the [ __ ] you know swamps in louisiana
and whatnot where they're taking
you know they'd go and shoot like a
nutria or something like that and then
they would
yeah and make like stew out of it swamp
rat
yeah and and it's really like okay i
like that he's
um kind of highlighting people that take
like what other people would consider
like shitty ingredients or just garbage
ingredients and making something really
really good out of it yeah i know what
to do with it
yeah bee's nest says is there going to
be a mongolian dog recipe
no no no dogs no cats we're not going
there
[Laughter]
i'm not even going to take you down the
[ __ ] i'm not going to take you to
armadillo on the half shell or dillard
on the half shell
you're not going to eat armadillo okay
nobody wants to eat no
my cajun my cajun i know but my cousins
are cajuns
you know and they [ __ ] eat armor they
eat [ __ ]
they use they don't eat it anymore all
right they kind of outgrew that [ __ ]
it's
it's 2020. but back in the 80s they were
[ __ ] eating diller on a half shell
and [ __ ] possum
all right diller on the half shells of
an armadillo
all right you cook it a certain way
clean it all out then you
mix it with stuffing and put it back
inside that shell and [ __ ]
bake it all right and then armadillo is
basically a maggot all right they eat
dead [ __ ]
they carry leprosy it's [ __ ] terrible
it's terrible to eat something like that
and they weren't going out hunting
armadillo it was [ __ ] roadkill
they go that's fresh which you're just
asking for
yeah they're [ __ ] crazy food
poisoning and these are not savages
these are modern people that are
armadillos are armadillos are adorable
okay but they're scavengers yeah it's
not a good idea to eat
in a scavenger hunt you wouldn't eat a
buzzard yeah in louisiana
back in the 80s if the cajuns saw a dead
animal
in the road they'd stop and check see if
it's fresh
yeah because it's free it's free right
that's some crazy [ __ ]
just like the jelly and the hot sauce
and waffle house and these are not
these are not [ __ ] savages living out
on [ __ ] pee roll
you know what pee roll is do you it's a
[ __ ] floating house
boat they're not living in piro they're
not [ __ ]
living in trailers and [ __ ] they're
suburban people
eating roadkill well you know you're
[ __ ] crazy
you can
you told me that story the other day
i've heard that story before but you
told me it again
oh
[Laughter]
okay we gotta get back to the show
didn't honey boo boo and family dine on
roadkill that sounds like something they
would have done
i never like watched that show but yeah
they probably do that i heard about
stuff secondhand
so yeah um can we talk about the casey
anthony case now
like i said she's she's probably
watching this but she probably got bored
like because
we're already an hour and we're not even
talking about her maybe we're safe
we're gonna talk about you casey
[Laughter]
like i said i don't want to be an
[ __ ] but like we're gonna see
she she did say something about this is
what i was talking about when you came
in
she did say something well one there was
a pro
i don't know how far along the proposal
uh you know pathway this went
but there was kind of like an idea
floated
that her and oj were gonna have like a
reality show
like because they were both like pete
innocent people that were accused and i
was like oh jay was just like really
dude
okay but as i said
and like i said i'm saying this right
now i'm not saying
i'm not defending casey anthony i'm
really not
but i don't think that she deliberately
premeditatedly
killed that baby i think that it
happened accidentally or as a result of
her neglect and then she covered it up
possibly with the help of her father
because her father is also
a super weirdo her mom is also a super
weirdo the whole family
is super weird except like i said the
brother lee seems
okay um i mean casey made some
allegations against him which i'll get
into
in a while but i don't know
the entire family because a lot of
people have talked about casey being a
compulsive liar which she is but
i think a lot of people neglect that her
parents are also
or her dad is also a compulsive liar so
i think that's kind of like where she
got it from
maybe it's genetic yeah i don't know if
it's genetic or if that's just like the
way she was raised or something like
that this entire family
seems to have a real problem even before
the whole even before kaylee died they
seem to have a real problem
dealing with reality or dealing with
difficult situations
and they're first paired yeah and their
first instinct
is to pretend that it's not happening
the way it's clearly happening
so i feel like the [ __ ] where like if
this baby
like died accidentally or as a result of
someone's negligence or whatever
i feel like it's very on brand for them
to have just
said okay well we're just gonna pretend
this didn't happen
we're just gonna bury her and pretend it
didn't happen i feel like that's very on
brand for them
because [ __ ] that happened because i
kind of want to get into that a little
bit
too [ __ ] that happened even like you
know prior to this
even when like casey was pregnant with
kaylee
that suggested to me that this is a
family that cannot
deal with the reality that's right in
front of them and that's kind of their
first instinct is to say
well it's fine nothing like nothing bad
is happening
it's very very weird their whole family
is weird
and not normal so
i'm just going to say that right at the
outset it's just it's a very weird
situation where's the story begin
so all right so let's kind of talk about
uh you know kaylee anthony obviously is
the victim in all of this
this poor blameless little baby who was
almost three years old now she was
living
in orlando right here where we are yeah
uh with her mother casey obviously who i
think was in her early 20s at the time
she was 22 something like that
um and they were always also living in
the house with casey's
parents george and cindy
now just an overview
july 15 2008 kaylee was reported
missing now cindy kaylee's casey's mom
made the 911 call and reported her
missing
not it was a really weird call like i've
heard the 911 call she wasn't
necessarily reporting her missing but
she was just saying i haven't seen her
in 31 days and casey won't tell me where
she is
she's not reporting it like she thinks
she's dead
she's not reporting it like she thinks
she's been
kidnapped she's just it's almost kind of
like
she called the police i think
to get casey to tell her where kaylee
was
you know what i mean it seemed like that
to me because i think casey was there
like sitting next to her like when the
911 call was made that's what i
you know thought from the call and
you know i want to get into that later
too like the whole relationship like i
said the relationship between all of
these
like between casey and her mother and
her father is just like super super
weird so i want to get into that too
so uh basically cindy says
i haven't seen kaylee for 31 days she
also mentioned on this phone call
that she thought that casey's car
smelled like a dead body and this is
another big point of contention and i'll
kind of get into that later on too
cindy says to the cops she's like look
casey has been telling me like all of
these really weird things about where
kaylie is like for these 31 days that
she's been missing she's been telling me
oh she's with
this nanny which is another thing i want
to get into it's like oh she's
you know she's here she's there she's
danny took her to the beach she's here
she's
another place and it's like i'm kind of
getting sick of it i don't know where
she's at
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
finally
casey gets taken into custody and
basically her story was
that kaylee was kidnapped by her nanny
zanny uh short for zaneta gonzalez
fernandez i think was the name it was
like
yeah yes um and she kind of
gave police a run around she was kind of
like driving around looking for this
person
it's like they went to this apartment
where she supposedly lived nobody lived
there
she's like no let's go to like universal
studios because i work there and maybe
the nanny took her there they go to
universal they're like look she doesn't
work here
she's looking around for some office
that doesn't exist or whatever so
finally they arrest her
now it actually took they they kind of
kept up this weird charade for like
six months that the kid was missing
that she had been kidnapped by the nanny
even though even from the beginning
because i listened to the cops
questioning casey about this [ __ ]
uh the cops clearly did not buy it um
from very early on in the investigation
they were trying to get her to like
say what had happened but she wouldn't
but the body was actually not found for
six
months um you know after
she had been reported missing or after
she after they think that she died
so she was finally found she was already
a skeleton at this point
now the weird thing about it is that
like i said i'm just kind of giving a
brief overview and then i want to kind
of get into like all the specifics of
the case because i read this really like
fascinating book about it
where it went into like a lot of the
points of contention at the trial
and is pointing out the whole book was
coming at it from the point of like a
lot of people were pissed off that
you know spoiler alert that uh casey got
acquitted
but the book was saying look i'm not
defending her but
i'm just telling you why she got
acquitted this is the stuff that came
out at the trial this is stuff the
defense did this stuff the prosecution
did
and we're saying that the that the jury
given the information that they
heard gave the only possible decision
that they could have given because they
just didn't have a lot of physical
evidence
i think there was another factor though
too what's that do you have a picture of
casey anthony
not on me now okay i thought maybe you
had it in there you could show them no
guys never seen casey casey's cute
how a defendant looks actually [ __ ]
has a lot it does
sadly it is it is a factor sure if casey
was an ugly girl
that [ __ ] would be in prison i do not
disagree
that's what happened on that yeah and
i'm not saying that's good that's not
good
it's just like juries are yeah they're
like we're not gonna throw that pretty
girl away
they're not yeah if you're if you're
pretty or handsome if you're a dude
um you can get away with a lot more than
an ugly person
and that sucks um that's not how it
should be
but that's human nature that's kind of
how [ __ ] works
yep which juries are just humans
and the judges are humans too and
they're like well
i'm gonna give this one a light sentence
it's gonna be [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
although i have to say that the jury in
this case i read a lot of their
uh she was the first offender a bunch of
the jury members
did like ask me anything kind of things
on reddit or they gave interviews like
afterward
and they seemed pretty with it
um and they seemed to know um
when they were being manipulated they
seem to know i mean they all seemed very
intelligent and they seemed to know what
was going on with the case
and a lot of them had qualms but they
were like look
the prosecution didn't prove their [ __ ]
and it's like we can't
you know it's as much as they maybe
didn't like her they didn't like the
family they're like they just didn't
have the evidence and
we didn't have any other choice years
back
years back this must have been around
this is before i met you so this one's
been in 2009 2009 2010
i was on one of those on a true crime
thread somewhere on the internet and
somebody's
was they were talking about one case and
then somebody brought up
this is after casey anthony so it must
have been later
2012 maybe well the casey anthony trial
was in 2011 2000
this was the death of 2008. this is
later then this is around 12.
because i already knew you then i think
i met you we knew each other we weren't
a couple then
no but we met each other in 2009 i was i
was looking at something having to do a
true crime and somebody mentioned the
casey anthony case then somebody else
says isn't this
isn't this casey right here and it
[ __ ] and they left a link
and there's a link to a [ __ ] backpage
site
in a place where normally girls are
[ __ ] selling it
but she was um it was an ad
for being a cuddle buddy
yeah and the photograph of the girl
people were in the comments because yeah
that
looks like her now i don't know if it's
true or not
could have been that it might have been
a joke somebody placed that ad and put
[ __ ] casey anthony's picture on there
that's the thing
but it was but it was funny it was i
feel like
a lot of this is she working as a cuddle
buddy well i think a lot of it like i
said and
like i said i don't want to get buddy to
get the impression that i'm defending
her anything but it's
like i do feel like a lot of the [ __ ]
that came out in the media
because i feel like people still
nowadays
you know think of this case as like oh
that girl that
killed her baby and stuck her in the
trunk so she could go out and party
but that's not really what happened and
that's not even
when the little girl is most likely to
have died
it wasn't at night no one was out
partying at the time
no one was it was like in the middle of
an afternoon like of a weekday
um you know casey was at home with the
baby
it was you know the dad was at home with
the baby so it wasn't a case of her
and she didn't really go out and party
that much
it i think people just because she was
photographed a few times
like out at clubs after her
daughter died and
you know people were like well she's out
there acting normal when all the time
she knew her
daughter was dead and that is like very
very weird behavior
but i said that they thought i was
accurate about the [ __ ] the ad or her
being a cuddle buddy
yeah i don't know i don't know if she
was or not at least at that time
there were in that thread there was
about seven or eight people going
yeah i think that's hurt i was going
back there and looking looking at that
[ __ ]
uh that um backpage ad and it did look
like her
it looked like her and it wasn't like a
and it was just like a candid type shot
right about not a [ __ ] you know
portrait or anything yeah it did look
like her
and the guy they were in there
discussing is that casey anthony and it
was you know of course it wasn't using
her name
but i was thinking that maybe somebody
found a picture casey anthony and just
put well there were a lot of pictures of
her i mean because she did get she went
to fusion
ultra lounge yeah have we ever been she
went to fusion
yeah no [ __ ] well her boyfriend at the
time was like a
promoter like he promoted events there
so she would go on friday nights because
she was always trying to like hype up
his nights because that was her
boyfriend
fusion so she always kind of like
managed the shot girls and [ __ ] like
that
few the fusion club was the one over
there near where they where they shout
out the gay people right
isn't it that around that same pulse
isn't that your pulse
oh it might be i think it was i think
we've been to fusion at least once
we were in the in the parking lot of
pulse one time remember
that wasn't pulse that was um or was
that fusion
because we because a long time ago mini
me was in there spinning
yeah i remember that that might have
been was that fusion
i think maybe that's what i was thinking
i think that was fusion it might have
been
so if you guys don't know who minnie me
is there's this little dude who [ __ ]
was in love with me and [ __ ]
dressing like me this is years back
dressing like me and following me around
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] getting girls to impress me and
then [ __ ] he was just
this [ __ ] was just looking like some
other fatal attraction man
that was some weird ass [ __ ] but he was
or like single white females yeah the
dude was trying to adopt my identity
all hundreds so like i said single way
female 125 pounds of that little [ __ ]
that's why i called him minnie me that
was so good dude you can't beat me
you know what i mean and and it was so
weird and he was a lover though that was
some weird [ __ ]
i told you there's some weird [ __ ] i
didn't realize that at the time
he had girlfriends he had a chinese girl
that was kind of like his
what would you call that well she lived
in his
i mean they lived together yeah he was
she was older than him
yeah and she was like she came over here
in a [ __ ] crate
in a storage crate oh that's what she
said that's what she said she wasn't a
legal citizen
and he kind of kept her in the houses
like a girlfriend
but he had other girlfriends slash maid
yeah girlfriend i think he just wanted
somebody to take care of him
yeah and like in order for her to
to her to stay in that place she had to
be involved in all these threesomes and
[ __ ]
and then he tried to give her to me
remember that
yeah that was special he tried to give
her to me yeah yeah
i was like nah which just goes to show
how how much
regard he had for her yeah yeah
i guess you could say like a slave well
like i said i think he just kept her
there because he liked somebody that
would like clean up after him
and you're not so he was not a tough
domineering guy he was a little bitty
effeminate
[ __ ] well he's very young really
young at a family
late 20s early 30s like when we knew him
yeah
yeah that was a very very small dude
that was a weird time in our
weird time in the situation
that was a weird time in our lives
whatever happened to that day me
yeah if i bought that if i bought it he
bought it
yeah you would buy an outfit and come
out in it and then like a week later he
would buy the same one
yeah like maybe in a different color but
it would be the same thing
yeah remember he bought that jacket that
you had but he bought it in like this
weird like traffic cone orange color
yeah do you remember that remember when
you send me this text i love you
i love you sending me texts i love you i
know i told you
how dare you betray me like what are you
talking about do you remember that night
you were staying at my apartment because
i had an apartment over on aloma
back at the time and you were staying
there at the time yeah and that one
night
we had gone out and then we went home
and he had been there
and he got mad about so i don't even
know what he was mad about we didn't
fight or anything but it's like when we
got back to the
apartment yeah we both started getting
like he started blowing up both our
phones
yes send me texts and [ __ ] yeah all
night and he was just sending texts to
both to you
and to me like all night long like you
betrayed and we were like what the [ __ ]
are
is he talking like dude you got you've
got a chinese [ __ ] house girl and a
bunch of girlfriends we didn't know
what he was talking about like with the
israelites
yeah well because you went to my house
and like you should have gone with it
i guess [ __ ] him and his entourage of
[ __ ] little girls
it's so weird yeah it's a weird [ __ ]
he's a weird dude
florida's a weird place sometimes well
everybody knows that florida is a
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] place
got scenes everywhere a weird place i
mean every scene is weird zach are you
in there i should have sold that [ __ ]
to you man i
i i should have sold you i should have
sold that boy to you
you loved it
you'd have to lose all that weight back
though that he's been sitting around the
house zach's been sitting in that house
[ __ ] gaining weight he said
he said he gained 40 pounds 30 pounds 30
pounds let's not get excited
that's right no [ __ ] mini me you had
to be skinny
i guess i don't know he was very skinny
yeah he was giddy yeah
well he was very short too he might have
been shorter than me and i'm pretty
[ __ ] yeah he's about five too
that is sure he was like he was like
prince yeah yeah like that like a white
prince
but not dressing like me but not nearly
as cool
no no and here's the scary thing people
he was a school teacher
yeah i don't know if he still is or he's
a high school teacher i don't think he
lives there anymore
yeah yeah that was another thing that
was weird about him was that he
like i mean this house and there'd be
[ __ ]
high school girls over yeah that like
they graduated and now oh now we can
hang out
and [ __ ] and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
up with this [ __ ] which seems a little
it's not illegal or anything but it just
seems a little
didn't you know they were all they were
all the hotties questionable yeah it
seems a little
questionable like hey when you graduate
what's going on here back and look me up
yeah that seems a little weird
it seems a little weird i'll just yeah
is that why you got into teaching
yeah yeah so uh yeah what was i saying i
don't know
you don't know you weren't listening i
don't know yeah so like i said six
months later
they find kaylie's skeletal remains
in like wrapped in a like a laundry bag
and there was like another bag and they
found it not
behind the anthony family house but
a little bit down the street like on the
same street
now another thing i want to get into too
is this whole
duct tape thing because i'm not sure
like how much
because i like i said i feel like people
have a thing nowadays where it's like oh
there was duct tape over the mouth or
something like that which is not
exactly the case um it's a little bit
i feel like the way it was portrayed in
the media was a little more cut and
dried than
it actually was but you know that's kind
of par for the course
so as i said now at the end of the case
um
casey was uh acquitted
and so a lot of people got like really
uh outraged about that and
understandably so i mean
a little three-year-old girl dies
obviously somebody is responsible for
her death they couldn't find any
evidence on the body of murder like
there was no cause of death they
couldn't determine what that was because
she was skeletonized
it was no sign of trauma or anything
like that so they couldn't determine
you know she hadn't been strangled
obviously she hadn't been stabbed
championed anything like that
so they couldn't determine how she had
died so they couldn't really it was very
hard for them to prove murder
um so it was much more likely like i
said that she had died accidentally or
as a result of
accidentally and or as a result of
neglect
and that they had just covered the
murder covered up the murder which again
that's not good and you should still be
in prison for that but i'm just saying i
don't think
it was uh premeditated in that way
so uh all right now
here's the thing so okay so what
happened on
the day now this is probably the day
that kaylee died
um because this is the the last day that
anybody
apparently saw her
now according to casey anthony's dad
george who again is problematic we'll
get into that in a little bit
according to him casey and kaylee
left the house this was june 16th 2008.
um casey left the house with the
daughter
at you know that afternoon like around
noonish or something like that
and then he didn't see them again you
know what i'm saying so he's saying that
that's the last time
that he saw kaley alive however
later phone records later computer
records later other things
um prove that this was not
the case the actual case
was that casey was
at the house until
at least a little past 4 pm
that day because they know because of
her computer records her computer
searches her phone
uh her cell phone like where it was
pinging from they know she was at the
house until about 4 p.m
george was also at the house probably
until about 2 45 pm because he went to
work at 3 and his work was about 10
minutes away
so it seems that casey
and her dad were at the house
at the same time that afternoon and
kaylee
probably never left the house so
something
happened that afternoon
that either somebody killed the baby
which like i said i don't i don't really
see any evidence of that
or the baby died accidentally and
they didn't know how to deal with it and
thought the best thing to do was cover
up the murder
which again or cover up the death which
again
why would you do that i don't know but
so
okay so that's what george said
initially that
i just i last saw them it was about noon
and like
kaylee and casey like went out the door
and i didn't see them again
for more than a month for 31 days
now according to cindy casey's mother
she was like repeatedly asking all
during this month where is kaylee like
what's going on
it's like can i see her it's my
granddaughter
but casey always came up with some
excuse um you know oh
i took her to tampa like we had a work
assignment we went to busch gardens it's
like oh she's with the nanny
you know zaneta or zanny or whatever she
called her
um you know and and all these other she
always had an excuse as to why like her
mom couldn't see her why her mom
couldn't call her
and her mom started kind of getting
suspicious about like why
not necessarily suspicious just why like
why can't i see my granddaughter
now another thing that happened right
around this time period
was that casey's car had been
towed it had been left near a dumpster
like by an amscott uh check cashing
place
and it had been abandoned there for a
few days and finally like a tow company
came and got it and towed it to like an
impound lot
now normally what would happen in these
situations
is that if a car gets towed to an
impound lot the
people at the lot will send like a
registered letter
to the address that's on the
registration and will say hey your car's
been towed
you know you owe x amount of money
you've you know come pick it up
at your convenience or whatever now the
people at the impound lot said that they
sent a letter
on i believe it was uh july 11th
was the date that they sent it um but i
don't know if this was ever received or
not but they sent another one
and then finally like george
says that he gets this registered letter
and he goes to pick up the
car which was casey's car it was like a
white pontiac sunfire
so he goes to pick it up and
both him and the dude that like worked
at the impound lot
they said wow this car like really
smells or there's like a really bad
smell coming from the trunk
now it's kind of complicated because
both of them said
at varying times that they thought that
it smelled like a dead body
but i'm not sure how much weight to put
on this because the her
the testimony changed like several times
like during the course of the whole
investigation
but let's just say it's like okay so
they both thought it smelled like it
smelled really bad or whatever
now they opened the trunk and
kind of the story they let out to the
media so there was a bag of garbage in
the trunk that's all that was in there
was no body there was nothing like that
there was a bag of garbage in the trunk
very popularly in the media they said
though there was some pizza and there
was rotting and there's maggots on it
it wasn't actually a pizza it was just
like an empty pizza box
um one thing that was in the garbage
though and this might have
contributed a lot to a lot of the [ __ ]
that happened later on about the trunk
and everything
um was that and this is super gross
is that there was like an empty water
bottle or an empty soda bottle that had
a bunch of
um uh that had a bunch of like
tobacco spit in it which
human saliva has a lot of the same
uh chemicals that dead bodies would have
in them and especially if they've been
sitting
in a trunk in the florida heat for
three weeks four weeks however long it
was at this point
um could certainly cause like a really
bad smell or a decomposition smell
and might have contributed to some of
the [ __ ] that happened later on but yeah
so there's a bag of garbage in there
so they thought okay well it must be the
garbage making that smell
so the dude from the impound lot like
takes the bag
out of the trunk and like throws it over
the
over the fence like into a dumpster and
then apparently like george
just drives the car home with the
windows open because the car smelled so
bad he didn't report anything he didn't
call casey even though later he said
oh i thought i smelled the dead body in
the car and i was worried because my
grand
daughter was missing and my daughter was
missing and blah blah
but he basically just drove the car home
even though it stunk
and parked it and just went to work like
nothing was wrong and then he
didn't call his daughter he didn't do
anything like that so
again a little strange but maybe casey's
dad is a little weird too
i have to this whole family is weird
could be though that you know
you just don't want to make that mental
leap that somebody got killed in the car
you go man that's kind of odd
you know what i mean they're missing
type of deal the bit the kid's missing
it does smell bad in here
nah couldn't be something like that you
know what i mean although i have to say
that
after looking at all the trial
transcripts and after looking at all
this stuff i'm not really sure
that there was ever actually i'm not
saying that like
obviously you know the baby died
but i don't think the baby was ever in
the trunk yeah that might have been
something that was added huh
no i think well i think there was other
explanations like the pizza
but the garbage and stuff in the car
well it was garbage i don't think it was
pizza because
a lot of people said it was pizza but it
was just a bot it was an empty pizza box
something that wasn't reported not that
bad well no that
well what i'm saying is that that was
what was reported to be oh was rotting
pizza and those maggots
but something that wasn't really
reported in the media a lot was that in
the garbage bag
that there was a bottle with um tobacco
spit in it
like a lot of tobacco spit that was
thank you and like i said saliva
like human saliva has a lot of has a
couple of the same chemicals that a
decomposing body would have
so and you know there was a you know
people were talking about like oh there
was a stain on the carpet in the trunk
and stuff but it didn't look anything
like a decomposing
so i don't think that there was so he
was dipping
yeah so i don't think that you know and
i'm not saying that i mean casey
obviously knew that her daughter was
dead and obviously
hid the body this is the south now all
right
yeah this is florida if y'all don't know
what [ __ ] dip
is all right tobacco spit what they're
talking about you might be in another
country
we have this pro we have this we have
this uh
product called smokeless tobacco been
around [ __ ]
centuries all right skull and copenhagen
or is it called copenhagen yeah this is
called copenhagen
there's also chew you know it's just
yeah it's just piece of tobacco you put
it in your mouth
and you just kind of like if you're into
that yeah and it
i'll tell you what though i used to
smoke and even like chewing tobacco
that's like still i used to use skull
when i was in the army because you are
you're not allowed to smoke at night
because through night vision goggles it
looks like yeah like a car headlight
yeah so if you really need it if you're
nicking out you'd put a little bit of
[ __ ]
hate i use copenhagen too but it was
it's real fine cut it gets all over your
mouth i like skull wintergreen i like
that one
and you can put it in your between your
your your your lip and your gum
and after a few minutes like you smoked
a cigarette and if you're not a smoker
you'll get [ __ ] high as hell you'll
throw up if you're not a smoker
but if you're a smoker it'll satisfy
real well smoking
urges there was a time when i was in the
army where i would smoke and dip
i'd have a dip in my mouth and [ __ ]
dragging off a cigarette at the same
time
you know not all the time but sometimes
i would you know uh
i liked it but you got to spit you know
what i mean you're [ __ ]
yeah it's your saliva glands start
activating
and you can't swallow it you'll throw up
you know what i mean it's [ __ ] bad
real bad on your stomach so
you got to be spitting you don't want to
walk around spitting everywhere so you
usually just take it down
coke bottle and spit it into the coke
bottle when you're done
you just look and put the damn cap on
the coke bottle screw the cap back on
throw it away or you know that's what we
were doing with
man i gotta tell you this reminded me of
[ __ ] dude i went to basic training
with we show up in korea all right we're
in
we're in downtown
tonkashan casey
all right and we are [ __ ] blasted
everybody's dancing on the dance floor
i'm [ __ ]
drunk as [ __ ] my buddy wins back there
you know and he's [ __ ] dipping into
the bottle
and [ __ ] everybody's just loaded and
we're drinking each other's drinks and i
[ __ ]
he's sitting there and bottle up in his
mouth and i grab it and take a big belt
out of it and
throw it on and he was dipping in the
[ __ ] bottle he wasn't drinking
dude yeah yeah i took a big [ __ ]
switch i have to tell you like not a lot
will make me like gag yeah since we were
talking about mystery science theater
earlier
there is one host segment in there
where crow decides to take up chewing
tobacco
yeah and he has all these pop cans like
around like soda cans like around the
the bridge there that have his spittle
in them
yeah and they have like all these like
gross brown drips like around the
outside and then mike comes in and he
has a soda and he like puts down the
soda that he can't remember
yeah which one is his soda and which one
is like the spittoons
yeah and it's like that that's what
happened well i thought he was drinking
he was spitting and i grabbed it he
thought i was going to spit in he
thought i was dipping but no i drank and
he just no no no no
too late that that host segment is
hilarious
but it makes me gag every single time i
see it
every single time my boy wins so gross
last name is win w-i-n even reading
about one
because i was when i was reading a book
about this case and they were they he
went into great detail
about this bottle that was in this in
the garbage bag in the trunk
that had all of this tobacco spit in it
even just reading that made me want to
throw up
for some reason that's really really
gross to me yeah
you know what i mean they're laughing
how disgusting that was filthy gardner
says disgusting but what could you
expect from a band
yeah i agree that's like pretty [ __ ]
gross it was funny you know what wants
to spit it up
it didn't matter we just kept going we
were all [ __ ] up
you know what i mean and it was it was
army time you know what i mean [ __ ]
we all lived together it didn't matter
never mind that reminded me like apropos
of nothing but that reminded me of a
story that my brother told me which also
kind of made me gag
where he was i don't remember if it was
the house he was in now or the house he
was in like with his wife and kids
earlier
but he was talking about he was doing
some renovation or something around the
house
and this is florida um florida is very
swampy and very buggy which will
you know become important later but he
had been working around the house and he
had a soda can
and he wasn't really looking at it for a
while and i guess
he was like working over here and then
like he went to take a sip out of the
can
and i guess a whole bunch of bugs had
crawled into the can
like while he wasn't looking and he
drank it and there was like all these
[ __ ] german cockroaches in there
and he told me this [ __ ] story and i
was just like oh yeah i gotta go barf
bye michael's in there asking for
grandparents or put snuff on on bee
stings yeah
i remember that yeah and that was the
thing yeah they put [ __ ] stuff
that's some mississippi [ __ ] and that's
not some [ __ ] that my dad's generation
do that'd be like a grandparents
generation
would do that [ __ ] that was old people
doing that
real old but i remember that
a lot of crazy [ __ ] southerners used to
do i remember all kind of [ __ ] that
people well one thing i remember too is
that
if you go on the beaches in florida like
in daytona or something like that if you
get stung by
a jellyfish you're supposed to pee on it
yeah like that nitric acid or something
i think is what they said
neutralizes it which i don't know if
that's true or not but it really does
that was kind of like an urban legend
that was going around so every time
you'd get like
it's an urban legend but it comes from
[ __ ] california surfers yeah
so you get so sometimes because every
now and then because i grew up in
daytona beach and like
you know sometimes you would go to the
beach and there'd be all these dead
jellyfish like all the way down the
shore
and my mom be like don't touch them
don't touch them someone might still be
alive
but it's like if you still touch it or
if you went in the water and like one of
them kind of got you they're putting p
on a p on it like i said i don't know
how effective that was
it might be probably effective probably
from what i hear
sheila ann says toothpaste on wasp and
bee stings
paste not gel okay okay
i believe it all right so let's see
so at this point as i said um
the cops are finding it a little bit
suspicious
that evidently this little almost
three-year-old girl
has been missing for a month and no one
has thought to
report that so they think that's a
little suspicious very odd yeah very
good
it is very odd like i said this is a
weird [ __ ] family i will i'm going to
say that right now
82 people watching now hello how is
everybody hi
82 people yeah
yeah rebecca says in australia we're
taught peeing on jellyfish stings
and the peeing on it is [ __ ] i think
it is too i think it is
i think it's a [ __ ] it was a surfer
thing yeah and i heard it too growing up
in florida because like i said
maybe it feels better just for a few
seconds like running water on something
probably yeah tim bray said casey's dad
is really weird i agree
um i feel like casey being a compulsive
liar
i feel like maybe that's where she got
that from because her dad is also a
compulsive liar
and the weird thing about their
compulsive lying is that
sometimes they lie
like in an understandable way like that
is
self-serving or whatever but then
sometimes they just lie about [ __ ] that
doesn't matter
or they lie about [ __ ] that's going to
hurt them or
because you know for an example george
anthony her dad
he testified to his case he didn't
testify but george anthony
testified extensively at the trial
some of the [ __ ] he said it almost
seemed like he was testifying
to get casey the death penalty because
the death penalty was on the table
you know uh at first and it almost
seemed like he was trying to make her
guilty but then like when he would talk
to other people like when he did
interviews later
he was almost kind of like lying to like
exonerate her
so it seemed like there's no rhyme or
reason to the lying it's just it
it's almost like lying is like a reflex
yeah
which i feel like is kind of par for the
course for her and for her dad so maybe
that's where she got that from because
she lied about [ __ ]
that mattered and also [ __ ] that didn't
matter that she didn't have to lie about
which was another thing that i thought
was like really strange about her
and the weird thing about her too is
that like when she was um
when she was uh evaluated by
psychiatrists like before she did the
trial like to you know to determine like
whether she was saying
like to do the trial or whatever even
though she didn't testify
um the psychologist said that she seemed
normal which i'm not sure if i believe
that or not
like i watched this other guy like if
you guys don't know there's this dude
named uh
dr todd grande and he has this really
good channel on youtube
and he pretty much analyzes every
[ __ ] he'll like serial killers
politicians
everybody like he analyzed he's like
look he says in the beginning he was a
disclaimer he's like look i don't know
this person i'm not like you know
offering a diagnosis or anything i'm
just telling you like what
i'm seeing like from the way they behave
you know in public and whatever so he's
just kind of like giving
his assessment of it and he thought it
was very very strange
that the psychologist that evaluated
casey anthony
didn't find anything mentally wrong with
her and thought she was largely normal
because he's like to me he's like i'm
not gonna go and say she was like a
straight-up sociopath
but she seemed at least like a
compulsive liar or somebody that
had real um you know
she was like denial thing you know what
i mean she was always like denying
everything
i think it was because she had grown up
in this weird family
where you basically had to pretend
everything was okay at all times
otherwise you would get yelled at or
you'd be in trouble because i do feel
like her mom
was kind of like this real like
overbearing everything has to be perfect
and everybody has to go
along with my delusion about how
everything's okay and if you didn't like
you'd get yelled at or you'd get
reprimanded so i feel like both her and
george
were kind of used to their whole entire
lives
just pretending everything was all right
and even if
things were obviously not all right and
here i'll get into the thing
even when casey was pregnant with kaylee
anthony
and she would go somewhere and she was
very obviously pregnant okay she had
like the belly the [ __ ]
her [ __ ] belly button was sticking
out everything like and the family
members be like
hey when she do or like hey she's
pregnant
her mom cindy she's not pregnant she's
just bloated
she would say [ __ ] like that like her
mom
was like denying that she was pregnant
until
almost until the baby was born until she
was like seven or eight months pregnant
that's some crazy people
that's right her whole family did they
know that she was pregnant
or they were just playing along i don't
know yeah
i don't know like her mom was she's a
virgin
which obviously she wasn't she was like
21 or 22.
and she had a boyfriend that's some
weird [ __ ] so i kind of feel like
that's funny like as shitty as this
whole situation is and this poor little
three-year-old child like had to
die for this [ __ ] as shitty this
[ __ ] is i feel like casey's
parents are all so terrible they're just
like
really really this is a whole
this family is very very messed up like
the whole dynamic of this family is
messed up
like i said the brother casey's brother
lee seems pretty much okay
he seems pretty normal but casey and her
parents
i don't know what happened there it's
just like this super weird dynamic
because there was this whole thing where
prior to casey getting pregnant like
this is even before like all of this
[ __ ] happened like
prior to casey getting pregnant her
parents
like george was a compulsive liar going
back to
his ex-wife like 30 years prior also
said he was a compulsive liar so that's
like something that he had going
like a long time ago he also had a
gambling problem he was real
um he was uh real into escorts and
prostitutes and stuff like that but he
would always like lie about it
so he had that whole thing going on and
then
it's weird because him and cindy were
together and it seemed like
even though he stepped out on her even
though he went to prostitutes while they
were together
it almost seemed like they were together
like
as long as as long as
george let cindy like run everything
that and as long as she could pretend
that everything was okay
and he didn't like he would never like
tell her like any upsetting information
or anything just like to
keep from getting her all upset
so as long as that was going on then
like peace was maintained
you know what i mean but they had
actually
separated for a while i think they were
actually separated when
kate when casey got pregnant with kaylee
but then they got together later on and
george
explicitly said later on that casey
was one of the reasons that they had
separated because
cindy would not hear anything about
um casey being a fuck-up
like the whole thing about her
pretending she had jobs
because like i'm assuming that a lot of
people like know at least like the
outline of this case because this is a
very very famous case at least in the
u.s
she like said that she worked at
universal she said she worked at sports
authority and she didn't work there
but the weird thing about it is before
she got pregnant
she did actually have a job she worked
at universal she didn't work for
universal she worked for kodak
you know those people that you know when
you go to a theme park and like they
take your picture
like on the rides and you get off the
ride and they try to sell you the
picture
you know what i mean you know those
people yeah she worked at one of those
kiosks so she worked for
kodak um you know who had the kiosk
inside of universal studios so she did
actually work there for a couple of
years
and she was actually like a
well-regarded employee
now what ended up happening was when she
got pregnant
and as as far as i know nobody knows who
the father
is said she worked as a waitress at
glory holes
really that's [ __ ] ridiculous
do you want me to refresh that drink um
yeah i might as well okay
but yeah so she didn't have a job for a
time and then she got pregnant
and then she basically went on maternity
leave and then she just didn't go back
and after that time period it seems like
she was almost kind of like well [ __ ] it
i'm not gonna like have a job anymore
but she kept telling her
family that she had a job now
i think that her dad george knew that
she didn't really have a job and was
just pretending to have a job
i think they were both pretending that
she had a job
to maintain the illusion for the mom
cindy like to because cindy's whole
thing was she liked to like pretend that
everything was okay
so i do kind of feel like they were
almost like maintaining this illusion
for her benefit even though i kind of
think that she knew that probably
casey didn't really have a job really
either
but it was like this weird
alternate reality she had constructed
and she didn't really want anybody to
like [ __ ] on it
it was it's just it's hard to understand
like people that have like
a normal you know psychological profile
and like a normal
family dynamic it's just very weird to
understand like it's very hard to
understand like how weird this [ __ ]
family was
but the more i read about them the more
like
i was just i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on with these people but yeah
so i feel like cindy wanted
to maintain the illusion that everything
was okay that
casey was that casey hadn't got pregnant
at 19 that she really did have a job
that she was really
going because it was this whole thing
too thank you put that curry on real low
oh okay we'll have some later yeah
because there was another thing too not
just the pregnancy but even prior to
that
so here's another thing that happened
prior to that this i know this is like
rambling but i'm just like this is just
[ __ ] that's like occurring to me at the
time
another thing that happened uh prior to
that was that when
casey was in high school she was
actually a pretty decent
student like you know she turned up she
had her [ __ ] she was like you know you
know a's and b's she was doing okay
and um but then at some point she kind
of decided [ __ ] it is like she didn't
really want to
like apply herself anymore so she came
up like a few credits
short to graduate right
now apparently casey knew this for a
while
like she knew that she would need to
like make up x amount of credits to
graduate
in time with the rest of her class but
she didn't tell her family
that right so by the time
that her fam so her family had like
thrown this big graduation party for
like all the family was there all their
friends were there and everything
they didn't tell anybody and from what i
could determine
the mom and the dad went to the
graduation ceremony
ceremony for the high school even though
casey wasn't graduating because she
didn't have enough credits
they went to the graduation and then
everybody
the family members that were there too
were like why isn't casey like walking
across the stage and it's like
oh well they they made a mistake they
like [ __ ] her on the credits or
something like that she was supposed to
graduate but
so it just seems like this weird like
delusion that they're all participating
in yeah weird
which to me kind of sounds like keeping
up with the jones
yeah and i feel like cindy was like
graduating
yeah like she didn't want anything to
like shatter this illusion that she had
of this like perfect family
so i feel like that's very so i feel
like it's very on brand
if something terrible like i said just
horribly if something terrible happened
to this baby
even if it was just accidental i feel
like that's the first thing all of them
would do
was we need to like cover this up
somehow
like we don't want anybody knowing about
it
and i don't you know it's like to us
it seems like stupid because it's like
you know obviously you're not gonna get
away with that like it's gonna look very
suspicious
but i think they thought well we're just
gonna like you know cover [ __ ] up and
then like we'll just
this sounds genetic it it really does
like the more i was reading about her
and her dad and the problems that they
had like in their family the more i was
like this
whole family is messed up and to be
honest with you like i said i don't want
to get sued for like defamation or
anything like that but i definitely do
i don't think because there are some
people out there not me
there are some people out there that
think george anthony the dad
actually killed the baby or was
molesting the baby
because there was there were a couple he
did say a couple weird things okay
um can i just say that he uh
reportedly was there when casey gave
birth like was in the room
when casey gave birth and said something
about how excited he was to see the
baby's vagina
what which that's a weird [ __ ]
weird um are they taking this out of
context no no no
he did say that um and he also said
something weird like when they did the
eulogy
like at kaylee's funeral like
about how he missed the smell of her
sweat
that's some weird [ __ ] again weird
that's weird
um you know he said weird [ __ ] um
[Music]
but some people have used that to say
well maybe he was a child molester also
uh another weird thing was that the
skeleton that when they found her
skeleton
the pair of shorts that they found that
she had presumably
been wearing when she was buried were a
pair that
were a size too small for her and that
her mom
said well she hadn't or her grandmother
said well i haven't seen those shorts in
like
since like 2007 they were too little for
her
so why would she be wearing them
some people used that to say that maybe
george had been molesting the little
girl and that he
didn't know that those shorts were too
small for her and he was just like
trying to hurriedly like put some
clothes on her
and just grab something out of a drawer
that was like an old
shirt though but like i said that is
yeah that is can that is completely like
speculation
i don't think and and what they know i
know this is like kind of weird but like
what they know of george's
internet search history and everything
because they had to go all through that
[ __ ]
it's not a fun job um he did look at a
lot of porn he did go to a lot of
escorts and stuff like that but it does
seem like
the escorts that he went to the porn
that he looked at were age-appropriate
like they were
some women his age so he didn't seem
like a pedophile
um but some people have speculated that
maybe he was doing something and casey
actually at the trial did actually um
make the conjecture that george had been
molesting her
when she was a teenager which i don't
know if that's true or not she also
said that her brother lee had
touched her boobs while she was sleeping
which
i don't know if that's true or not like
lee seems like an okay dude but i don't
know
if that's the case it could it could be
hard to know what's true in a family
full of [ __ ] liars
that's what i mean and and that's the
thing it's like i don't
i hate to like discount like anybody
that says you know oh my parents or my
brother or whatever
molesting me i don't want to like just
across the board say like oh you're
making it up
but casey is a compulsive liar
i mean so you can't and it's sad because
she's lied so much
that you can't take anything she says at
face value because
it got to a point where even though they
a lot of her friends were actually um
put on the stand at the trial
and most of her friend i mean as far as
i know like all of her friends said she
was
she was a really good mother she would
have never done anything to hurt her
baby um you know so
there was that but her friends
also pretty much across the board said
well we all knew that she just like
made up stories yeah that was just
what she did and she did
provably steal from some of her friends
um you know she would write checks out
of their account like if they were out
of town or whatever
one thing that she would do and this is
going back to like what i'm saying about
like making up lies about when you
didn't necessarily have to
she would do [ __ ] like she would make
plans with somebody like
her friend amy like who was her her best
friend amy huzinga i think is her last
name
or if i'm pronouncing it right they were
supposed to
they had made plans like amy was gonna
go buy a new car and they were gonna go
to jacksonville which is
you know about a what one and a half
hour drive from here yeah
so they were gonna go and do that and
they were gonna do that together they
made plans
and then um casey at the last minute
calls amy and says oh my father had a
stroke
i can't go with you her one her father
had not had a stroke
um and i think the issue here and we
were
i was telling you about this earlier i
think the issue here is that
she was one of those kind of people that
didn't really
want to let anybody down but she always
wanted to have an excuse if she didn't
want to do something she just like
couldn't
she couldn't come out and say i don't
want to do that or i don't want to
you know help you with like your car or
whatever so she always had to come up
with some excuse why she couldn't do it
yeah because it seemed like she had an
excuse for everything
now t's in there going where does this
kind of insecurity come from and i think
during the time she made that asked that
question that was during the time where
you were saying that casey's parents
went to her graduation when she wasn't
graduating
yeah where does this kind of insecurity
come from
okay
you're dealing with where is this
neighborhood again do you remember where
it was that she lived in
where was she they lived over by
waterford lakes which
um is kind of near to where my apartment
used to be it's over by ucf
okay so it's work it's upper working
class middle class
yeah yeah okay sometimes you have this
kind of thing that i've noticed
in a lot of really it's reflecting you
know i'm white so i'm gonna say it's
with white
suburban middle class and upper middle
class people
they're very competitive they want to
have
what other people like what their
neighbors have
all right [ __ ] buys a boat this
dude's got to have a boat
you know what i mean another
[ __ ] buys a damn camaro
he's gotta have the camaro because
they're trying to be the same
yeah and the only reason why they're
trying to be the same is because they're
not the same
they're different and they feel
uncomfortable about it
so probably what you have in a situation
like this is you have a family of people
who
they don't feel the same as their
neighbors but they have to
but they feel like they have to prove
that they're the same
so when casey doesn't graduate on time
they have to they have to [ __ ]
overcompensate
almost kind of like no no she did
graduate on time the school just [ __ ]
her
yeah our daughter is the same as yours
yeah well that's exactly the vibe that i
got
right and that's that's a warning sign
and that was mostly
that was mostly the mom i feel like that
was mostly the mom that that was coming
from
yeah and i feel like the dad george um
as shitty a person as i think he is
because i think he's a shitty person
and i think he uh you know allegedly i
think he knows what happened
to kaylee that day because i think he i
don't think he did it but i think he was
there and he would and he helped casey
hide the body
i do think that i do think that that's
my opinion yeah
um but i think that he was for some
reason
was terrified of his wife
and everybody had to maintain his wife's
illusion that everything was okay yeah
which means
you know you're dealing with you're
dealing with people that
feel essentially they feel substandard
they feel that they're not as good as
everybody else around them
so they have to thank you hayden holy
crap holy crap
yeah damn thank you so much jesus christ
thank you very much thank you
thank you man we got somebody got some
money to throw around
is it because i was pumping out that
wisdom
you're dealing with you're dealing with
somebody that you're dealing with people
that
don't feel up to snuff yeah
so they have to [ __ ] double down on
their efforts to feel like they're the
same
as their other middle class neighbors
when you see somebody like that it's
kind of a warning sign
yeah that's i give a [ __ ] about what my
neighbors think about me
i don't even know what my neighbors are
they're all they're cool though
you know but i don't really care what
they're doing they got a swimming pool
next door
that's not making me [ __ ] go jenny
we got to put out nine new books so we
can put a swimming pool back there
because i wouldn't swim in that [ __ ]
anyway
well the thing is our neighborhood has a
swimming pool yeah
and i like to swim i've only i've only
swim in that thing
maybe once or twice yeah i would like to
have a swimming pool but i don't want to
take care of this woman right
[ __ ] this so i kind of like that the
neighborhood has one
so you can go use it if you want to but
you don't have to take care of it yeah
we're in an enclosed community we're in
what they call a gated community
all right and the gated community has a
community swimming pool yeah
but our neighbor the house next to us
he paid to put that [ __ ] in there not
all of them have it
but that's making me going like oh man
my dick is so small i gotta go
i'm not even [ __ ] thinking about that
now swimming pool i like it
well the older i get the more i think of
because
even when i look at like people's houses
like oh they have a bigger house than me
i'm like maybe it doesn't really matter
so much to clean yeah more that's all i
can think of
and honestly like i said i really really
like to swim and sometimes i would be
like oh it'd be nice to have a swimming
pool but then i'm like
man i want to clean that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
right it's much nicer just to live in a
community that has one
yeah and you just go swimming into like
off hours with like a bunch of other
people
casey anthony's parents were living in
this house
they saw that [ __ ] next door
building down swimming pool
i guarantee her dad would be [ __ ]
pulling his hair out trying to figure
out how the hell he's gonna get
i kind of i got that vibe from he's one
of those kind of guys
these are one of these you know i hate
to say it but this is
this is one of these like kind of basic
families that are kind of like well
i don't have what all my neighbors have
right
and so i have to so it seemed like they
were willing to
essentially yeah just knit this entire
reality of and
that's why i think that kaylee
dying and as i said i don't think it was
on purpose i don't think it was
premeditated i don't think anything like
that i'll go into like the cert
the google searches and everything like
that later on
tammy says pool party at tom and jenny's
house
come down here for a pool party that's
just gonna be [ __ ] naked
you have video cameras and everything
i'm gonna call the whole lighting crew
people that we [ __ ] do do the videos
with [ __ ] make like [ __ ] starry
night [ __ ] music videos
it's gonna be wild it probably would be
[ __ ]
that we know you don't come down here
and make offers about coming [ __ ]
swimming or swimming pool
unless you're gonna [ __ ] never mind
we've had as as long as we've lived here
i think we've had one
big party we had a party here we've had
some smaller ones but we had one
party at this house [ __ ] this [ __ ]
was wild and people are still talking
about some of the [ __ ] we had all these
[ __ ]
all these [ __ ] we didn't have a bull
all these golf kids and [ __ ] half
these [ __ ]
goth girls are [ __ ] strippers [ __ ]
had a dj in here the smoke machine
[ __ ] lasers [ __ ] uh i made a whole
bunch of indians
yeah we had a whole indian food buffet
we even had the vegan black metal
chef vegan back middle chef was here and
he brought his own
vegan dishes brian manowicz brian
manowicz yeah we had him here he was
here awesome
yeah it was it was quite a thing and we
had that was such a fun party yeah it
was like the lights were [ __ ] shining
out across this [ __ ]
upper middle class neighborhood and
[ __ ] all the neighbors were pissed
because
with all the lasers coming out the front
door because we have glass fronts
you're playing [ __ ] industrial music
and [ __ ] yeah we got we had industrial
it was a combination of like industrial
and like 80s and 80s
retro wave type of [ __ ] yeah and then
and
everybody was [ __ ] cute everybody was
[ __ ] cute
that was a fun part you were ugly you
weren't in here
i remember that party as like i remember
being in the kitchen
because we were all pouring our drinks
we had all the solo cups and everything
and i remember talking to
laura and adam in the kitchen and we
were just like so yeah
we were all so wasted and we were just
like
i thought it was gonna bust out into
[ __ ] semi-nude nude orgy i didn't
know it was
this is some rock star [ __ ] people not
lying you know what's awesome
the next day they didn't look at us the
same way after that [ __ ] did they
no the neighbors are like what the [ __ ]
are you guys doing bigfoot all these
tattooed [ __ ] people with [ __ ]
hair extensions and [ __ ]
like what the hell was that 15 inch
[ __ ] platform heels and coming in the
house
yeah one thing i will say say though
and i don't know if this is true of the
goth scene in general yeah
but you know we had this like rager
everyone's like out smoking dope on the
you know porch or whatever and it's like
we had all this [ __ ] going on we had a
dj
we had so much so much liquor so much
food
and yeah the next day
it was i had like i had
almost nothing to clean up the only
thing that i had to clean up
was people had kind of tracked some dirt
in from outside like from the porch like
they were out there smoking pot or
whatever and then layla came in and
there was like a little bit of dirt on
the floor
other than that everyone was very very
like everyone had thrown their cups away
in the garbage can
everyone had put their dishes away
everyone i was like
wow like no there was no like big huge
mess
it's like i was amazed i was amazed at
how little mess everyone had left
i was like wow our friends are awesome
you know what i mean
that was a couple years back now huh it
was a few years ago all right i gotta
pee you gotta talk okay yeah should i
play the commercials
um you can if you want you took like
three pooky videos
so do fv3 commercial right there and
then pookie one pookie two pookie three
okay
i'll play them on whatever you want to
play but got the [ __ ] in the control
i'm taking the con taking the car
okay ladies and gentlemen now's the time
let me put my [ __ ] glasses on
we're gonna go what did she yeah she
told me uh ft
fb3 you love true crime i love true
crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing
unsolved murders of the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies case
the frog boys the alcasar murders and
the anoka shira park dismemberment
incident
the faithless villain volume 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
all right y'all ready for some pookie
videos i took these [ __ ] videos today
just before the [ __ ] show
started check this out
there we go i just got back at the right
time
you gotta go now yeah
oh okay
i'm back ladies and gentlemen
so yeah so here's the thing where was i
all right i could you know i realized
this is kind of rambling but whatever so
like i said she she'd been lying about
everything about having a nanny um
spoiler alert
the nanny that she said that the little
girl was with all this time
didn't exist like she existed in the
sense that there was a person
with that name but that person
did not know her and to not like
it's hilarious because when they
okay when they took casey into custody
they didn't initially
take her into custody as like a murder
suspect they initially
um took her into custody they didn't
read her miranda rights they didn't do
anything like that because
they thought well at this stage she was
saying that the nanny
uh zaneda or zany as she was called had
kidnapped the baby and that casey didn't
know where she was
so at this stage the police were
operating under the assumption even
though you can tell
like from the tapes where they were
interrogating her which i listened to
um that they didn't really believe it
entirely
but they were like driving her around
and they're like okay we'll take us to
where zany lives
like take us here and there in the other
place they take her to this apartment
complex was called sawgrass which
you know i know what that where that is
it's like around here
but so they go there and it's like
they found out later that the apartment
that supposedly this woman lived in
was like had been vacant and had been
vacant for a very long time
and then she's like oh well take me to
universal that's my office is there
maybe zany took her there so they go to
universal and they like fart around
there for like a really long time and
then
she goes to this place she goes to
universal and she goes in the offices
they don't know where she is
and then she pulls a full care and then
she's like what are you talking about i
work here
i'm this person i'm that person that
person and then she like walks through
the halls
finally like i'll show you where my
office is and she's supposedly like
she's apparently like waving at people
going hey steve
hey whoever and it's like pretending
like she actually works there
and then she like goes down this one
hall
and then she goes down this other hall
and it's like a dead end
and then finally she's to the cops okay
i lied i don't work here
like and she hadn't worked there
since like 2004 2005 something like that
and
like i said technically she didn't work
for universal she worked for kodak
inside the universal theme park and she
only worked there for a little while
until she got pregnant
and then she got pregnant she didn't
come back from maternity
leave so they fired her she had been
telling everybody
oh pokey you got her back inside
just walked in yeah oh good girl
this little baby she's the best baby
open it
she can't open that no she can't yeah
she's like look at this [ __ ] use
your hand to hook that [ __ ] open
she's like no it's much easier for you
to do it
but yeah so that's the thing so she
she kind of like it sucks because she
led them on this big long like goose
chase
pretending that someone had kidnapped
the baby when she knew all along what
had happened to the baby
which like i said that to me
even though i don't think she murdered
her
um but that to me is kind of
unforgivable even though yes there were
you know extenuating circumstances yes
her parents were messed up
yes i can understand why her first
instinct
when something really bad happened was
to deny everything
i get that but that's not
what you do and you're wasting the
police's time
um you know where your baby is you and
possibly your father allegedly are the
ones who buried her
and you know where she is this whole
time and you're making them think that
the baby might still be alive somewhere
or that someone else took her
and that's just really shitty you know
what i mean so
she's still shitty i'm not saying that
i'm just saying i don't think she
planned to like
kill her ahead of time so let's kind of
talk about that though because i kind of
feel like some people
and i think somebody commented earlier
on that i think a lot of the perception
of this case
because you said this too when i told
you about casey anthony because you
hadn't really like read anything about
her no
i just remembered it right and i think
people like nowadays when you remember
it because it was like 12 years ago
when you remember like oh wasn't that
that girl that
put duct tape over her daughter's mouth
and stuck her in the trunk and then she
died and then she tried to cover it up
but that's not what happened um and the
thing about it is that
in a way and i can see why why people
are so
upset that she got acquitted like i said
i
i think she probably should have been
held responsible for more than she was
held responsible for
but you have to think too that
the way it probably really happened was
not
the way that the media portrayed it and
was not the way that people remember it
now well they're going to take whatever
things that they hear and reconstruct it
make it as sensational and salacious as
possible
that's what i'm saying not what really
happened it's probably something a lot
more understandable
i'm going to tell you right here what i
think happened you told me but go ahead
you tell them
i never really knew i i don't know if
this is what happened but this is what i
think happened
i think that
george the dad and casey
were at the house that day like they
usually were as i said
for the mom's benefit cindy's benefit
um casey would usually pretend to go to
work
um and cindy i don't know if she
actually knew she was going to work or
if she was just
playing along with it because she just
wanted that to be true
um because at this point she said oh i
don't work for universal she said she
was an event planner
and she would like say oh i have to go
here she said i have a work laptop i
have to go on business trips she like
invented like all this stuff so like i
said it was an elaborate
ruse that she maintained most of her
friends
um seemed to know that it was [ __ ]
and they were just kind of like oh well
that's how casey does
she's just makes stuff up and that's
just there we're just kind of used to it
and as i said i'm not sure how much her
mother
knew that she was bullshitting but was
just like in denial because she wanted
her illusion to be maintained um
but casey had been for years
pretending to go to work
just for her mother's benefit
even though a lot of things say it was
her for her parents benefit but george
he didn't go to work until three in the
afternoon he knew
that casey was at home all day
because they know from phone records
from
search records on the computers things
like that they know that casey was at
home
and they know that george was at home so
they know that they were both at home at
the same time
so they're like ergo george must have
known
that casey did not have a job all this
time and that she just hung out at the
house
with kaylee and on this particular day
the last day that kaylee was seen alive
um because she had a cause kaylee had
actually been seen alive
uh june 15th was the last day and they
know
that she was alive that day because they
had taken her to see
her great-grandfather at um
you know the the nursing home where he
was at and there's video of her
and it's dated and everything like that
and
cindy said that it's like okay we took
her to the you know to the
nursing home and then we brought her
home and we put her to bed and blah blah
blah
and then the next day cindy got up and
went to work because cindy had a
full-time job
and then presumably casey
george and kaylee were alone in the
house
after that time now as i said george
initially told the police that casey and
kaylee had left the house around noon
that day
but they know that that is not true
because
the computer records and the phone
records the
cell phone records uh you know
particularly
casey's cell phone records show that she
was at the house until at least
four o'clock p.m and that george was
there
until probably 2 45 p.m
and they think that whatever happened to
kaylee
happened sometime
around 1 50
to 2 15 p.m somewhere in that span
it must have happened somewhere on that
span now the interesting thing
is that when you pull when you look at
uh the phone like uh
casey's phone records from that day
casey had been talking to her friend
amy she talked to her for i believe
36 minutes like that early afternoon
like normal [ __ ] had been good she'd
been talking on the phone to friends and
like on
you know she'd been posting on their
facebook walls and [ __ ] like that like
all that morning
it was like normal [ __ ] nobody said
anything like
that she was acting weird or anything
like that
but then she talks to her friend amy for
like 36 minutes on this early afternoon
of like june 16th or whatever
and then there's a there's a gap of
about 30 minutes
where there is no phone activity and
there's no computer activity
and they think that whatever happened to
kaylee happened in this window
this 30 minutes because after this 30
minutes
it seemed like weirder [ __ ] started to
happen like
casey talked on um i can't remember if
it was online or on the phone
to her ex-fiance who's i think his name
was jessie
and jesse at that time he said well she
was acting kind of weird
like she seemed like she was acting very
weird
and then there was um there was also
some she made like a whole bunch of
phone calls to her mom
which i guess her mom didn't answer
because her mom was at work which her
mom didn't answer
and so there was like there was a gap
and then there was like a lot of weird
activity and like her friend said that
she was acting differently like prior to
that she had been acting differently
i think what happened in that time
period and this is
i'm not the only person to think this
i've seen other people that have this
as well that have this theory as well i
think what happened
is that during the time that casey was
on the phone with her friend
and wasn't watching kaylee because that
was something that her friend
now her friends did say she was a really
good mom she loved that baby she
wouldn't have done anything to harm the
baby and i believe that
um but one thing that her friends did
say was that sometimes she would leave
that baby
by herself like while she went off to
like talk on the phone or like
fart around on the internet or whatever
like so she wouldn't watch her for like
some time and this kid was only she
wasn't even three yet
yeah but i i don't think that is being i
don't think that is very unusual
it's not that unusual 70s that's true
it's not
right in the 70s and [ __ ] we need to
have helicopter mobs yeah
yeah we just didn't be six years old i'm
[ __ ]
trying to get that it's true but but six
years old is different than
two and a half years old still a two and
a half year old kid can sleep a lot just
roll around make noises it doesn't
really matter
but obviously they're not in a dangerous
place they can't really hurt them yeah
but you know on the other hand it's like
a lot of bad [ __ ] could happen
and i think that's what happened in this
situation yeah i think what happened in
this situation was she was talking on
the phone to amy for
36 minutes which like i said they have
the phone records i know she was talking
to amy for 36 minutes
they were talking about normal [ __ ]
according to amy it's like nothing
unusual
i think that she wasn't watching the kid
during that time and i don't think
george was watching that kid either
i think what happened was that that
little baby
wandered into the backyard and the
anthony house had a
swimming pool like a raised swimming
pool now normally
you couldn't like the baby couldn't get
into the swimming pool because the
ladder they would
they were very um religious about taking
the latter off of the side of the
swimming pool
but like they had swum in the they had
swam in the pool like on the 15th like
the day before she was
uh she was killed but
the 16th nobody but the 17th when cindy
came back to the house she noticed that
the ladder
was on the side of the pool meaning that
either somebody
put it there or she had left it there
and forgotten to take it off which was
unusual for her because she didn't
normally
i think what happened was that somebody
left that ladder
on the side of the pool and kaylee
wandered into the backyard
and went into the pool because she was
really into the pool she liked to swim
and um several witnesses at the trial
said that kaylee like
really really liked pools and like you
know if there was a pool even when um
she was at apparently even when she was
at casey's boyfriend's apartment complex
and she saw the pool she would try to
get in it and casey would like try to
stop her and get
like hey like get out of there so she
really really liked and she was like
that was her
thing but she really wanted to get in
the pool so i feel like if somebody
left that ladder up accidentally maybe
i feel like that baby could have climbed
to the pool and
casey wasn't really paying attention she
was on the phone
and so a long time could have gone by
and that baby could have like climbed
over the pool and drowned
and then i feel like casey and the dad
then discovered
that the baby had drowned and didn't
and their first instinct weirdly was to
cover the murder up
because i definitely do allegedly
allegedly allegedly please don't sue me
i do think that the dad george knew what
happened to that baby
and he helped him he helped in hiding
the body i definitely do think that
amanda and t
are talking about the internet searches
do you know what they're talking about
yeah
i do want to kind of get into that okay
one second
i just wanted to announce that
assad is in the conversation assad from
saudi arabia good to have you back bro
assad from the house of saud okay
go ahead
[Laughter]
dude i'm [ __ ] into some i'm i'm ready
for some middle eastern food
just damn some kiwi that doesn't we
haven't made that in a long time i
haven't made that in a while
no some kb and some man
some some good [ __ ] middle eastern
[ __ ]
baked chicken that they had remember
that
she's gonna run in and throw the door
open she's like pong what are you guys
doing
here yes man go ahead and send me some
when you get a chance go ahead and send
me some good uh
recipes i got a cookbook coming soon man
it's going to have all the american
stuff in there all the southern stuff
and it's even going to be in it's going
to be both in english and
metric measurement systems so you can
make this [ __ ] anywhere
well i'm trying yeah i'm trying to do
like both
american measurements and metric
measurements because just like i'm
trying to do like fahrenheit and
celsius just because i know that a lot
of our fans are like not americans
yeah so we're trying to like keep that
in mind like when we're writing this
[ __ ]
but you know hopefully i i i do it okay
somehow my my uh little tab
has [ __ ] up go ahead jim yeah so
um some people said about the pool i'm
not sure if that's exactly what happened
but i do
think that the baby died accidentally
somehow
i'm not discounting that because some
people have said maybe george was like
molesting
the kid i think that's unlikely and died
but like
that's possible but i don't see a lot of
evidence supporting
that about it other than the shorts
which was kind of a big thing
but ah man there's a lot of things that
can that's what i'm saying it's like i'm
trying to be as diplomatic as possible
about this [ __ ]
that dude was into little [ __ ] girls
like that that being
in his porn search history
just saying i'm thinking
i don't think anything and the thing
about it is that i feel like
because a lot of people said well even
if like if the baby had turned up
dead like even as a
family as messed up as this one would
have called 9-1-1 i'm not so sure about
that because
the [ __ ] that i read about this family
about even what they had done like
like prior to this [ __ ] happening
this is not a normal family they do not
have normal reactions to things
they may have not known may not have
been able to relate to the normal
procedure
in western society i feel like they were
so
[Music]
it's really weird because i feel like
casey and george
in particular were so committed to
just lying about everything i don't even
know if they knew what real life was
anymore
it seems to me like they've they had
gotten to the point where
and it's hard for me to relate and i
guess it's like hard for normal people
to relate
but i was watching um there's another
true crime channel
uh i think her name's stephanie harlow
and she did like a four and a half hour
breakdown of this case uh it's in three
parts it's really good actually i
watched it
and um you know she's very like upset
with casey
and like i can see why like i don't
really like i'm not
down with this whole idea of her making
like a movie about it and like oh
i'm making a sexy movie about my truth
about the case it's like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i'm making a reality show with o.j
simpson [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's
you're profiting off the death of your
baby that's [ __ ] up
um so i'm not saying she's a great
person obviously she's not
um and you know her baby dying act
even accidentally and then her covering
it up and trying to make it seem like
and casting the blame on like a totally
innocent person because it seemed like
this
this nanny that she made up zanny there
was a real person
with that name but she didn't know her
so that woman is now having problems
like finding a job and everything like
that because like
now i look like the person that
kidnapped this baby or was like accused
of it and that's
it keeps coming up like in searches so
she's having a hard time
you know getting work and [ __ ] like that
so she's ruined this woman's life
just with all of her lies so it's like
she should be [ __ ] punished for that
and she's a shitty person for that
but let's talk like okay so some people
brought up the google searches
now a lot of people brought up the [ __ ]
that there were some google searches
done on these computers and they're
pretty sure that
casey did them because they were done at
a time
when either she would have been the only
one home
or the other searches that took or the
other internet activity that took place
around it
were [ __ ] that she would have done like
like more than her and her parents so
one of the searches very famously was
for chloroform
now there were some [ __ ] where
there was some surges made for
chloroform or how to make chloroform
now early on in the trial cindy um
casey's mom like she actually came
forward and said that she was the one
that made those searches that it's like
oh i was trying to search for
chlorophyll
because you know i was like one of our
pets like i thought i'd eaten something
and i thought it was like poisonous or
whatever so it's like i was looking for
that
and then it just defaulted to chloroform
and i accidentally
everybody knew that was [ __ ] the
jury knew that was [ __ ] even at the
time like
when they did the interviews everybody
knew that she was just trying to like
cover
for casey but i will say
i do think that casey um did search for
chloroform
but her defense did have a pretty good
backup for why she did that because
here's a thing that happened
a thing that happened and this might
have gone out to the media i can't
really remember but
i feel like the media made it
seem like chloroform or hadamard
chloroform was searched for
84 times that is not the case
um that's not what happened what
happened was
that this particular site had been
visited 84 times at the time that she
searched it she only searched it one
time she was only on this site
for a couple of minutes and
she was on this site because apparently
her
it was her boyfriend or her ex-boyfriend
at the time had posted on his myspace
which was a thing still a thing in 2008
myspace myspace is a dead ball
i know but it's still it was still a
thing in 2008 he had posted
a like a funny like well a weird like a
dark comic
meme on his facebook page
something about um you know dating or
it's like oh
i won her over with chloroform or
something like that
so apparently uh casey didn't know what
chloroform
was so she was google searching it
because she didn't know what it was
so the fact that she just google
searched it
right after she went to his myspace page
which they showed with the
uh with the computer records and also
that she was only on the site for a
couple of minutes it's not like she was
in there like trying to figure out how
to make it because
even if you're in there trying to figure
out how to make it
making chloroform is not
easy it's not you can't i mean it's
uh time consuming and it's really stinky
and it's really i mean if you're just
looking for a way to like sedate
your child which is what a lot of people
thought that she was doing
they're much easier this is terrible to
say but there are a lot of easier ways
to do that
um other than making chloroform which a
lot of people would
notice look t tila and [ __ ] amanda
and catherine they're all laughing about
our references to myspace but it was
yeah it was my about three months back i
got pissed off as hell
[ __ ] facebook i'm looking into my
facebook feed it was like looking into
the mouth of hell
everyone was just [ __ ] whining and
crying and i'm like [ __ ] these [ __ ]
i'm going back to myspace
so i tried to go back to my i tried to
go back to myspace and your browser
can't access it
you needed a certain app i haven't been
to myspace yeah you needed a certain app
on your tablet
in order to go back to my my profile
might be there for all i know yeah
evidently the last i heard
all those old profiles are there and i
mean i think i closed it but i don't
really remember
and mine is still there or it was but
modern browsers can't access it but
there was an
app for a while but the app's gone well
yeah i was gonna be
retro as [ __ ] i was gonna be i was gonna
be like a [ __ ]
hipster and go back to [ __ ] myspace i
don't like facebook
i'm taking my ball and i'm going home
i'm going home
and and evidently here are you guys i'm
going up yeah screw you guys
[Laughter]
evidently like back in 2015 2016
there was like a thousand myspace users
still active
dude said [ __ ] myspace a thousand
rings like a thousand that many yeah
there's like a thousand myspace units
i didn't even think it was still that
said [ __ ] facebook we're going back to
myspace
and evidently myspace was like like a
dead mall video
nothing but profiles from [ __ ] 10
years ago
no activity but there was like about a
thousand people on there worldwide that
we're still amanda marie
i need to go back to aol yeah it's like
going back to aol
that's just [ __ ] my mom still has it
my mom still has the aol account
that was back from the [ __ ] very
genesis of the goddamn internet that was
remember they would send you those
[ __ ] discs in the mail yeah
which everybody just used as coasters
what about when you turned aol on them
made the [ __ ] noises like like some
magical [ __ ] was happening like dude
dial it up man oh yeah i'm in the
internet now
i'm going on the world wide web yeah i
had
i had [ __ ] web tv hooked up to my
television when i was in mississippi
[ __ ] when you had to hook up and it
was showing a [ __ ] icon of a road
going by when you're loading
look like you're driving down the
[ __ ] street and [ __ ]
there's like something out of it out of
a out of a [ __ ] new retro wave
[ __ ] video on youtube you're going
somewhere
and then you show up to your myspace
account that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
it was badass back in the day i thought
i was i thought i was on schwarzenegger
man
i thought i was i don't know i thought i
was arnold schwarzenegger and running
man
in the running man movie you thought
this was like straight out of something
out of the running man
or [ __ ] total recall i was in the
future
i was i'm about to blow your mind no one
is ever in the future
you're always i was in i was in the
future back in 1998 i was in the [ __ ]
future in 1998 99 i was
i thought i was in the future yeah yeah
okay go ahead like i'm okay so i'm just
saying
that searching for chloroform it looks
bad and like i said there was one thing
there was one uh expert that said oh
well i did an
air sample of the air inside the trunk
of casey's car and it was like super
high in chloroform but
what you have to think is that two other
experts said that the
uh level of chloroform was normal
because chloroforms and a bunch of other
[ __ ] too it's not just
something that you um you know
knock people out with in old-timey crime
novels it's actually it's in like a
bunch of cleaning
products it's in like a bunch of [ __ ] so
it does turn up like in small amounts
like pretty much everywhere you want to
look where you've cleaned anything
so they couldn't really prove anything
in that regard and
the thing about it is that i i was
thinking about this when i was reading
it like i said i'm not
defending casey anthony because like i
said i still think she's a shitty person
and she
was shitty and not like reporting the
death right away which she should have
done
but if anybody looked at my search
history
i would be in big big trouble yeah
because she's [ __ ] researching crime
history you know
because all i do yeah i write true crime
i've researched this show
so i'm always i'm constantly like hey
like this person murdered that person
it's like how do you like what kind of
poison like kills would
you know what i mean so i'm always like
searching for that kind of [ __ ] so it's
like if i ever
got like if i ever got accused of a
crime
i would be super [ __ ] if anybody
looked at my search history because
i'm just saying it's so you can't really
like condemn somebody on that now the
whole thing too
there was a later search too for
um foolproof suffocation
now this search looks like it happened
somewhere in the window where
kaylee anthony probably died
now one book i was reading came up with
a kind of a plausible
uh situation as to how this could have
happened and like i said i don't know if
the little girl drowned i don't know if
she died some
other way like i said i do believe that
she died accidentally and then
casey and her dad because i think he
knew about it too
i think they made the very very stupid
decision
to hide it and to like cover it up
because they didn't want
the they didn't want the illusion that
they had
kept going to be shattered
so i think they definitely thought
well this is the best way to deal with
this we're just going to like bury it
and pretend it didn't happen because
that's kind of
what they did with a lot of [ __ ] so i
kind of feel like that's what they did
in this case as well
so i feel like so the search for
um foolproof suffocation
was done probably by k it could have
been done by george because i
he was at home uh sometime around this
time period so it could have been him as
well
i think it was probably casey that did
it though because the other searches
that took place around
this time period were also other [ __ ]
that she would have done
i think what happened is that the little
girl
died somehow accidentally drowning
however she died
and um i think that that
was maybe a way of
the link that she clicked on when she
did the search and then clicked on the
link
it was a suicide link like how
like how to commit suicide so i kind of
feel like
like her daughter died and then she's
like well how can i
kill myself but then she like changed
her mind
i so i kind of feel like that's where
that was coming from like i said i'm not
forgiving her i'm not i'm just saying
that's i i kind of feel like that's
probably what happened in that regard so
there was that whole issue like i said
now there was another thing to
let's talk about the duct tape
now as i said i feel like a lot of
people still have this conception
that um that the baby had been had died
and then was put in the trunk
and had duct tape on the mouth and there
was a heart-shaped sticker on the duct
tape
and then they buried the baby and then
they pretended blah blah
now i'm gonna say from the forensic
evidence i'm not entirely sure
that that body was ever in that car
maybe it was but i think it was like
pretty brief like some people did
say that the car smelled bad but the
weird thing about it is that
it's really like inconsistent like when
some people said
oh it smelled really bad or smell like a
dead body but then
some some people that were around the
car or said they were around the car
like way after the time that the kid
would have had
to have been in the trunk like didn't
smell anything or
were right there when casey opened the
trunk and they didn't see anything in
there or smell anything
so it seems like really inconsistent i'm
not saying there wasn't like stinky [ __ ]
in there
but like i said there was a bag of
garbage in the trunk when they picked it
up at the impound lot
that did have [ __ ] tobacco spit and
some other [ __ ] like in this garbage bag
which may have accounted for the smell
i'm just saying
so i don't know if the body was ever in
there now some people say yes they did
find one hair
that apparently had what they call death
banding or whatever it is they call it
um and they determined
they didn't have enough to say that this
was definitively
kaylie's hair but they did know that it
was like they did
mitochondrial dna so they know it was
actually so it was from somebody from
that maternal line so it was either
kaylie's hair it could have been casey's
hair could have been her mom's hair
could have been
you know what i mean so it could have
been a lot of people's hair they
determined that it was the baby's hair
because they said well this hair hadn't
been treated um
so you know kaylee or casey and her mom
cindy
and the grandmother or whatever they all
had dyed or bleached their hair or
permed it or something at some point
and it didn't have that so they
determined that it was probably the
baby's hair
and they're like apparently there's this
thing like i said i'm not a forensic
scientist so i'm not pretending like to
be an expert or anything
but apparently there's a thing that's
happened when you have like
a hair from like when somebody has died
or that's like off a corpse
and it has like this weird like darkened
banding like around the root
now apparently this one hair had that
but it wasn't definitive enough because
the hair
there was only one and the hair got sent
to like a bunch of different
uh forensic scientists and
it seemed like some of them said that
they thought it was from a corpse and
some of them not so much
and there are also there's a possibility
too that the chemicals from the garbage
that was in the trunk could have like
made this darkening so there was it was
too ambiguous
yeah they're like if there had been like
a whole bunch of hairs
like that then that would be another
story now jen
in the conversation is saying that both
her
her cop parrots feel that casey anthony
was guilty of murder
you have to understand that murder is a
legal definition
here in the united states and each state
has a different definition of what
murder is
although most of them are about the same
the legal definition in general for
murder is the intentional
killing of a human being you have to
prove
this that it's intentional there's no
way to improve
to prove with the evidence they have
here
the casey anthony killed her child on
purpose
that's the thing it's like i'm not
saying that she didn't i'm just saying
that they didn't have enough evidence
to that right because there was enough
[ __ ] to say
there was enough [ __ ] that you could say
like i said the whole [ __ ] about the
trunk
yeah they only found one hair the
banding on it was
ambiguous it's like it could have come
from a corpse it could have not it
wasn't even
necessarily uh kaylie's hair
it could have been you know someone
else's hair because like i said all they
had was mitochondrial dna so it could
have been any female
you know any any relative from that
matrilineal line
yeah a lot of people get confused about
first and second degree or third degree
and or manslaughter
first degree is the premeditated killing
of a human being you [ __ ] planned it
ahead first degree second degree is the
killing of a human being just
off the cuff in this yeah you just got
mad and you
no it's not even that well well it's
kind of like you killed somebody like in
the heat of the moment
uh no because manslaughter could be that
okay
second degree means you killed a person
and it wasn't premeditated
manslaughter tends to be in most states
are like the
killing of a human being but there was
sufficient provocation
to deprive the average person of calm
reasoning and cool reflection it's
usually something about like that
okay so
it's hard to prove it's hard to prove
all those
when you think about it yeah how can you
prove that somebody planned it well
you're gonna need paperwork you're gonna
need evidence that a person planned it
sometimes it's situational but it
depends on the jury
yeah the difference between second
degree and
manslaughter can be very slim just
depends on what the jury thinks
i feel like this may be because i feel
like she got off
because what the thing is the
prosecution was trying to do like
first-degree murder they were trying to
get the death penalty
i feel like had they gone for a lesser
charge i understand why they didn't
it was it was a play and they ended up
losing it
um if she had been convicted of say
manslaughter
um i would not have complained it
wouldn't have been's manslaughter
there's no way
there's no way because there's no way
that she in manslaughter should have
killed the kid because the kid made her
back
mad enough to kill the kid and and the
kid did something to her that was
so bad that the average person would
have [ __ ] struck out and killed the
person
all right self-defense or justifiable
homicide is the killing of a human being
in the act of self-defense the defense
of others
in a situation where you can reasonably
reasonably reasonably believe
that something like grievous bodily harm
or death would happen to you or someone
else
so when you have a jury that's con that
gets jury instructions like that and
they're confronted with this evidence
you can't prove that they did it
intentionally
you can't prove that they did it because
they were pissed off because the kid
pissed them off you can't prove that she
did it in self-defense because the kid
was going to hurt him
you can't prove that she just killed the
kid because she killed the kid the spur
of the moment
so that's the problem you have to be
able to prove
that's yeah for it to be murder there
has to be some kind of an intent
and i think that was where they were
lacking in this case because and that
was something that a lot of the jurors
said later on was that
and a lot of the jurors said this too
like because a lot of them did ask me
any things on reddit a lot of them did
interviews like after the fact
they were like look we're not saying
that like she's a cool person or like we
defend her anything but it's like the
prosecution just didn't prove it and a
lot of the [ __ ] that they brought
forth to kind of try to make her look
like a premeditated murderer
was obviously [ __ ] like all the [ __ ]
like the weird thing about her dad
was that they brought her dad on as a
witness
and he it almost seemed like he was
trying to get her
put like he was trying to get her the
death penalty because he was saying [ __ ]
about
um yeah the car smelled like a dead body
even though that's not what he said
originally like so it almost seemed like
that
so it seemed like he was trying to do
that but then like when he was around
other people like he would say other
things like no i think that
you know it was just an accident or
whatever but i'm just saying that
even if i okay i'm gonna say right i
don't think she intentionally
she that she planned ahead to murder
this baby i don't think that's what let
me tell you
i think that she died accidentally or as
a result
of uh casey's negligence there you go
which i think that's kind of the most
likely thing
most she wasn't watching her and
something bad happened i haven't checked
florida but most states have something
called negligent homicide
and that's where a person dies that's
where i'm going by your
lack of action that's where it was or
you did
something to put a person in danger and
they died
it's it's called negligent homicide
that's more if she had been convicted of
that
i would not have a problem right now
negligent homicide
in most states a negligent homicide the
maximum is 10
in terms of years in most states which
changes
average for negligent homicide to be
more like three
okay because it's an accident
so still people even though you might be
mad at this woman she wouldn't have done
a lot
a long time anyway well i feel like she
would have still been out well
well like i said i don't i don't agree
that she was completely acquitted
because she did cover up the [ __ ] and
they know that she
they know that she knew what happened
and lied about it there are child
cruelty statutes and [ __ ] like that that
could have been added on but you have to
prove them and there wasn't any
evidence of them that's what i'm saying
i'm just saying that's why all this [ __ ]
went down and that's why my boy
[ __ ] dr matt's little son and he was
about 25 at the time he was working at
this court
he told me about a week before the damn
verdict came down
that there's no evidence she's gonna
walk i they already knew
because there's no way to prove intent
honestly her
dad was a really um
she ended up he ended up like he
testified for the prosecution
in a lot of ways but he ended up like
helping the defense case a lot more
because he because he was notably caught
out in several several because he lied
about a bunch of [ __ ] too and so that's
why some people don't really know like
what his role in it was
because he lied about like okay for
example
when they found the body right and it
was uh
skeletonized and it was like in this
laundry bag it was in like a plastic bag
like inside of that and there was a
whole thing too like the dude that found
it was like he was like a meter reader i
think
roy uh what the [ __ ] was his name roy
krantz right something like that
so he finds the body he calls it in
and the cops didn't like he called the
tip line and they were like yeah
whatever we'll check up on that but they
never did so he called them again
and it's like there was this whole thing
it's like hey we already checked that
area there's nothing there
[ __ ] off and it took like a really long
time so there was some speculation like
the way that the body was found like the
one the way the skull was found
particularly because it was found it was
found like
upright which they don't think is the
way that the body decomposed because of
the way
like some of the dust settled or
whatever
they think that maybe the person that
found the body had maybe moved it
um just in the sense that not
not being like an [ __ ] but he was
just kind of like look
nobody is believing me like because he
had to call like a bunch of times like
before they would come out there
because he even called and like the cop
came out and he's like look i found the
body and like the cop
didn't want to go into like this area
where the body was he was like [ __ ] that
it's not there i'm you're lying or
whatever
so it's kind of like he had a call like
four or five times before the cops would
take him seriously
and i kind of feel like maybe nobody has
established
this allegedly i feel like maybe
that dude might have moved the body
closer to the road
so he could say look you know there it
is because there was a big reward by
this time
so i'm not blaming that guy because it
was like he wanted it was like 250
000 at this point so he had found the
body and nobody was listening to him
so i kind of feel like he's like maybe
if i moved it closer to the road because
the way they found it was like 19 feet
or 20 feet or something like that like
close
to the road and so i kind of feel like
maybe he moved it
maybe so that might have had to do
something with
how the [ __ ] was but so the thing about
the duct tape let's talk about that
because i feel like i wanted to talk
about that earlier and then i forgot
about it
so a lot of people have talked about
that it looked like
because they found pieces of duct tape
they weren't on the skull really
they were kind of like around the skull
or kind of just like on the skull but
they were just like
on one side there were like a couple
pieces of it that were like
going from the ear to like sort of the
midline of the skull but not on this
side of the skull and then there was
like another piece that was like kind of
found
nearby you know what i'm saying so a lot
of people
thought that that meant that the duct
tape
had been put on there like to suffocate
her
but i'm not sure if there's enough
evidence to support that
um because it does seem like the duct
tape
might have been because it was this
whole thing where
both the mom and the brother testified
that every time one of their pets died
right they would put the pet
in a plastic bag they would tie
the plastic bag up with duct tape and
then they would put in another bag and
they would bury it
so i kind of feel like that's what they
did with this
little girl is they did the same kind of
thing
so i feel like that the
the way that the duct tape was found it
didn't
look like it was over her mouth and nose
necessarily
like you couldn't really tell so i don't
think that was put there and i don't
think it was put there
before she died you know what i'm saying
they don't i don't think she was like
suffocated enough
it was just i don't know it's it's
possible but
it's unknown i don't think there's any
way to prove it
and like i said i'm not saying i'm not
saying that any of this [ __ ] didn't
happen i'm just saying that you can't
prove it and that's why i think
the jury in this case as shitty as it is
because i do think she should have been
convicted of at least negligence
negligent homicide
negligent homicide i i would not have a
problem with that i couldn't prove it
but i'm pretty sure
that's what it was that's i'm that's
what i'm leaning toward i think it was
negligible
yeah and had she been in a place that
was real tough like louisiana or
mississippi
and she wasn't so cute that [ __ ] would
have done five years
but she'd have been out by now five
years she would have still been
she'd still been out and like i said i
still think she's a shitty person she
uh she somehow did something and the
baby died
and it was kind of on her and she didn't
feel good about it so yeah
i do think she was responsible but it
in some way in some way but like i said
i think a lot of people said oh she was
like out of club partying but like i
said the little girl died like in the
middle of the afternoon
when casey was what exactly happened did
she
did she drug the kid and the kid died of
a drug overdose and then she hit it
although i should say that they did um a
toxicology
on the body and they didn't find
anything yeah that body was badly
decomposed but yeah but
you know what i'm just saying now the
[ __ ] tape over the mouth thing there
was i remember back in the day
they weren't sure if that tape was
actually over the mouth from what i
remember the [ __ ] body was pretty
rotten it might have been some taping
well it was a skeleton it's a skeleton
right
they think there might have been tape in
the area
the tape the investigators might have
thought that it was on the map
mouth there's there's just it's not
enough to lock a [ __ ]
from what they could determine this is
from what i understand from what they
could determine from what
all the forensic [ __ ] that i said
um a couple they found four pieces of
duct tape now they know that that came
from the anthony house so it's like
there's no the duct tape did come from
there they found the role in the house
they
they know that that's where the tape
came from so they know that
that her or her and her dad buried the
body they know that
so the tape that they found one piece of
it was kind of like
six and a half feet away from the body
something like that
and then there was another two pieces
that were kind of stuck together like
that like parallel
but they were they were stuck to the
hair
like back here and then it was kind of
like it kind of went
up here sort of to the mouth but it was
only about
to the midline or a little bit less so
it was only like
like that maybe and it was kind of like
stuck like that and then the other piece
i think was like not attached or was
just kind of hanging
so they couldn't really determine
whether the tape had been put there
prior to death
after death there was some speculate
like i've some seen some theories that
they put the tape on there after she had
decomposed like to keep the
mandible from dropping off the skull i
don't know why anyone would do that but
whatever
um but the tape didn't look like it was
in a position even before the girl
decomposed
that it would have suffocated the girl
you know i'm saying because it was only
like over like half of her face and like
half of it was over here
so it could be that the tape was just
kind of like
on the bag that they put over because
they put
the little girl in a bag and then they
put like that
plastic bag like in a laundry bag and
when they buried their pets that was
another thing they did they put them
like in a plastic bag and they taped it
up with duct tape and they
put it inside another bag and they bury
it so they speculated that this was like
something that they did in this case and
it had been six months
so they don't know how far apart and
like i said the dude that found the body
might have moved it as well even though
he wouldn't admit it
but and like i said i don't want to
impugn that guy's reputation because
like i said he was just trying to get
the reward money which i get that
um and he kept calling the cops to
report the skull and like no one was
listening
and and there was another [ __ ] too about
where
where the body was found allegedly like
some people had searched
that place before and hadn't found
anything
um that place that spot had also been
kind of underwater at some point so
there might have been some like floating
going on um and maybe that's why they
didn't find the body immediately
um so there there's like a lot of little
weird details about this case that don't
and it's really frustrating because when
i was reading the [ __ ] about it i'm like
nothing about this is clear like i still
have no idea
what happened in this case i know
the only thing i know like for certain
allegedly
is that casey obviously knew that her
daughter was dead
george probably knew that the daughter
was dead
and they specifically were like we need
to
cover this up for whatever reason i
don't know if they just didn't want to
get in trouble
or if something they did
you know caused the little baby's death
or because they weren't paying attention
to her
and like some kind of [ __ ] happened
there like i said negligent homicide
seems like
the most reasonable that seems very
reasonable to me
because it seems like they weren't
paying attention to her and she either
wandered off and got in the pool or
wandered off and something else bad
happened and then they made the stupid
decision that they're like okay well
we can't let anybody know about this
because
that was just what they did it seemed
like they just covered everything up
that was their first instinct this whole
family like i said the pregnancy the
graduation
all they had a history of this family of
any time anything unpleasant happened i
mean [ __ ]
casey was seven you guys casey was seven
months pregnant
and her mom was still telling people
that she was a virgin it's ridiculous
she's just bloated she's just bloated
her mom said
so i feel like this whole family like
their whole
shtick is if something bad happens
just pretend it didn't happen like you
know what i mean
so i feel like that's kind of like very
on brand for them like
the little girl dies accidentally as a
result of someone's negligence whatever
and their first instinct is we need to
like not let anybody know about this
because another thing too is that as
quote unquote normal as casey acted like
over the 31 days that her daughter was
allegedly missing when she obviously
knew that she was dead
and a lot of people point to that as
being like what the [ __ ] is the matter
with her she's a sociopath which she
very well may be
um you know but her boyfriend tony
did say that he woke up in the middle of
the night one night
and he saw her looking at her tablet or
her phone and she was watching videos of
kaylee and crying
so it does seem like this was all some
elaborate bruise that she was trying to
maintain for like other people
you know what i'm saying where
i don't know it just seemed like this
really weird reality that they were
constructing
where the little girl wasn't dead or
they were trying to pretend that she
never existed or
something and it seems [ __ ] up but
this family are crazy
they're crazy they they don't react to
things the way that normal people react
to things
i mean the more that i looked into her
history like the whole history of her
and her parents this is not
this is not a normal family these are
not normal people they do not have
normal reactions to things
and i feel like given their past history
if something bad had happened to that
little baby
that would have been their first
instinct which should be like we can't
let anybody know about
this so we just have to pretend it
didn't happen so i feel like that's kind
of what they did
and i th as messed up as it seems to us
because
even i mean if it was your kid you know
god forbid
that kill that you know drown in a pool
or whatever like
you know died in some accident or
whatever it's like the first thing you
would do is just like call the cops
you don't have anything to hide it was
an accident right but
i feel like that's not that wasn't their
first go-to
you know what i mean so i feel like that
was kind of like something that a lot of
people didn't really
because that wasn't what you would do so
i
so they kind of feel like and this
family is messed up i'm just saying this
whole family is messed up
and i've seen interviews with both the
parents and they both also seem like
terrible people they all just seem like
terrible people
but as terrible as they are i don't
think they killed that baby on purpose
i just think that something bad happened
like i said probably through their
negligence and they decided that the
best course of action
was to just bury the baby like they
would bury some of their own pets and
just hope that nobody came at them about
it
i i kind of feel like that's what
happened i think you're dealing with the
people that [ __ ] were very
embarrassed about what happened
scared yeah and you're kind of like a
limited scope of intelligence
i don't mean as an insult to you but you
got to be a dumb [ __ ] to realize
that you can't just bury a dead baby out
in the middle of the [ __ ] woods and
it's not going to come back on you of
course it's going to come back on you
well yeah
they know you had that kid but i think
they were kind of desperate
i don't think they murdered the kid i
think it was negligence i don't think so
yeah that's that's where i'm going to i
just think they weren't watching the
baby and the baby got into something or
something bad happened
they tried to hide it in some kind of
desperation which makes it look like
[ __ ] murder
yeah you should have just said look man
i was doing something in the kitten
and it and in this case never would have
been famous
well that's what i'm saying because
here's the thing like if you were okay
so like i said god forbid you have like
a little kid
and you're watching the little kid alone
one day like
hypothetically and you're doing some
other [ __ ]
you're cooking some [ __ ] or some
something that happens over here
and the little kid wanders off and
sticks their hand in the socket or
something
and they die now
obviously you call the cops the kids
dead you know they stuck their kids i
turn my back a second it's like
it happens obviously you're gonna look
bad
you know and this is terrible but like
that's how it's gonna play in the media
like why weren't you watching them why
weren't you doing this why were doing
that
like you you should have been watching
them every second you can't let them out
of your sight
but it's like realistically you have a
little kid
they're gonna get into [ __ ] you have to
go to the bathroom sometimes you have to
sleep sometimes
you don't know what they're doing 24 7.
so
i hate to say but sometimes bad shit's
going to happen because that kid's going
gonna get up in the middle of the night
they're gonna be like
hey i'm gonna stick because one thing
that my brother used to do
my brother he let you know those uh
things that you used to like use to like
put in the end of your corn cobs like
they're kind of like a
it's a plastic handle with like these
two little metal prongs on it
my brother when he was real little
he would get these out of the drawer and
he decided that these were perfect to
put
into the sockets in the house so
what would have happened if it had been
the middle of the night
3am my little brother wakes up and he
decides
i'm gonna go stick one of those [ __ ]
corn cob things into the socket because
he thinks that's where they go
which my mom used to say well he's
really smart he's like well that looks
like a socket so that's where i'm gonna
put it
you know what i mean because that's what
he thought
and so what if three o'clock in the
morning he decides he's gonna do that
and he electrocutes himself now
he's dead and then everybody in the
media is like blaming the parents it's
like why weren't you watching why
weren't you doing this and that the
other but it was like three o'clock in
the morning come on be reasonable
everyone's sleeping you thought he was
sleeping so i kind of feel like
maybe this is what happens now i'm not
saying it's good because it was the like
the middle of the afternoon i feel like
casey probably was like just yapping on
the phone to her friend and she wasn't
watching what her baby was doing
what she should have been doing because
she was awake you know what i mean
so and the kid wandered off and did
whatever she did
and ended up with her dying and
that's [ __ ] up she should have been
watching her but like you said
negligent homicide that's what it was
that's as far as i would go on this
but the fact that they then felt the
need
and like i said allegedly i do think her
dad knew what happened because he was
home
um around the time that they think that
kaylee died
so i do think the dad knew what was
going on and i think that he
helped to cover it up and then later
when he was on the stand he's like
he had this weird thing where he was
like trying to convict her but then
trying to not like depend on who he's
talking to what you're talking about
there
what you're talking about they're
covering [ __ ] up that that ends up being
obstruction
yeah uh obstruction i think they were
guilty of it
oh big time big time doesn't carry a lot
of weight
yeah you know what i mean is you don't
get a lot of time for obstruction
they still would have done in a harsher
legal system they had done about four or
five years that's that's what i'm gonna
say you know
four or five years yeah still not much
they'd have been a long time ago
yeah i mean i think that honestly to be
honest i think that both of them should
have gotten some jail time
rather than none at least for
obstruction
yeah because they i mean they knew that
both of them lied
yeah i mean they could prove that both
of them lied at least
even if they couldn't prove murder
well you can say that they hid the body
so therefore there must have been some
kind of a negligent homicide
yeah at the minimum that's what i'm
saying and i think they should have
gotten negligent homicide and
obstruction
yeah i kind of feel like that would have
been a better but but but the fact that
you know the prosecution we're trying to
get murder one they were trying to get
death penalty that's
overreaching which like i said i feel
like maybe i
i understand why they did it it's you
know it's
it's a thing that they do and it's like
well if if we're going for the death
penalty
we can it opens up a lot of
possibilities that you wouldn't have
like in
if you charge them with something lesser
so i can understand why they were doing
that but
i think that that maybe hurt them in the
end because
a lot of the jurors were kind of like
look we know she was guilty of something
but we don't think that there was any
premeditation
so you didn't prove negligent homicide
and they also couldn't prove that she
had
that there was any prior abuse because
nobody testified to that
everyone actually testified that she was
actually a lovely person and she was
like a really good mother
so they couldn't find anybody that would
testify against her in that regard so i
do kind of feel like
they may be overreached trying to get
murder one
if you had gone for negligent homicide
then probably you would have gone a lot
farther and like i said
allegedly allegedly i kind of feel like
they maybe should have looked into
george a little bit too
um just because not because i don't know
if i
buy the molestation stuff it could be
true
i don't know um they didn't really
produce a lot of evidence of it
but i definitely think and this is my
opinion
i definitely think that he knew what
happened to the baby
and i definitely think that he helped
her hide the body and he helped her
cover up for it i definitely think that
because he knew he was there
so you know
that said that's that's kind of all i
can say about it like i said i can
understand why they didn't want to give
her murder one because they didn't prove
that
they can't prove that but you know
i do get the [ __ ] and and some people
were saying too about some of the stuff
that was in the
trunk and let me uh talk about that for
a second
the [ __ ] that was in the trunk like i
said the garbage
and the dead body smell which the dead
body smell was kind of like inconsistent
because it seemed like some
when the cops came to the house when the
when the baby was first reported missing
which was 31
days after she presumably died
cops came to the house and came in
through the garage where the car was
and none of them reported smelling
anything even though
supposedly the body would have been in
the trunk like i said i don't think the
body was ever in the trunk i'm not
saying
like obviously they took the bodies and
buried it
but i don't think the car the body was
in the trunk or in the car for any
length of time
so i think the smell of it maybe came
from that garbage bag or came for some
other [ __ ] i don't think it came from
the body
but they like i said they found the hair
that was inconclusive
they said there was like a stain in the
trunk but
that also could have come from [ __ ] in
the garbage bag it wasn't like
definitive enough to say that that came
from a body
it didn't the trunk didn't look like a
trunk that it had a decomposing body in
it
to me you know what i'm saying i'm not a
forensic scientist like i said it just
didn't seem
definitive enough because when a body
when a body decomposes in a trunk
it will soak into the [ __ ] and it's like
dark
it like makes this big dark and it
didn't look like that
it just didn't it wasn't egregious
enough it just wasn't
so i feel like i'm not saying the body
wasn't in the car i'm just saying that
it wasn't in it
for a long enough period to you know
maybe she just
like threw the body in the back seat and
they took it and buried it
and you know maybe that contributed but
i don't think the body was in
the trunk and it was sitting in that
parking lot for like days and days
because obviously if if the body was in
the parking lot for like a few days and
it was like
this is florida and it was summer you
would have smelled that
for like from like
20 30 feet away easily like within a few
days
and nobody did that so i do kind of feel
like
there was something else going on there
um
but i don't know that that said this is
it's it's a really like complicated case
and like i said the [ __ ]
the fact that the [ __ ] family are so
weird and that they're so
cagey and that they don't really want to
admit to anything
and it's like they say one thing and
they say another thing and they say one
thing to one person and they say
something else to one person
like especially george he just seems
like very
george seems like a really weird
character to me it's like he said really
weird [ __ ] like
he'd say [ __ ] in the deposition and then
he would say [ __ ] like to the cops but
then
if he when he says [ __ ] like in an
interview when his wife is there
he'll say something completely different
so it really seems like
none like neither him or casey are
completely trustworthy
so i do feel like both of them
knew what happened to that baby and we
still don't know what happened
and like i said the fact that
she's talking about making them and i
think one of the good things that came
out of covid was that
they were talking about doing this movie
and now like i guess covet they can't do
it now
so but that was one of the things that
we're going to make this movie it was
kind of like
you know how remember how oj wrote that
[ __ ] book
yeah called if i did it yeah yeah he's
like yeah he made a lot of money on this
everybody knows that's the grip
bro not good everybody knows you did if
you did it come on
it's like at that point it just seems
like you're
are you tr you're just trolling us yeah
it's like everybody knows you did it
so it's kind of like you know you didn't
get convicted so allegedly
but everybody knows you did it so the
fact that you would come out
it's it's just really insulting that you
would come out with a book that says
if i did it this is how i would have
done it if i did do it but i didn't
it's like yeah whatever why would you do
that you're just trying to like make
money
and also he's trying to like say well
[ __ ] oj
i feel like he's like trying to see what
he could get away with
oj lost his power in the sports world
but he gained a new power
in [ __ ] celebrity crime
true crime celebrity so he wanted to
sell services basically
and books to kind of profit off that
look
i like oj oj killed them two people
though
uh yeah yeah he did allegedly had that
baby anybody else
had that been anybody else they'd gotten
[ __ ] convicted
yeah no [ __ ] now
it's not right to [ __ ] damn near cut
some woman's head off because she's
[ __ ] you over but i'm telling you one
thing
nicole simpson was [ __ ] oj over
i don't know if i buy that though she
was sucking up a lot of his money and
that
she didn't really it's like that she
didn't really love it that's no excuse
to cut someone's head off though it's
not
it's not man if i could just like cut
the head off of everyone that [ __ ] me
over i'd be like
i'd be a serial killer my understanding
is that this this was a hollywood
relationship you had oj you had nicole
brown
simpson nicole was she was i don't wanna
i'm not gonna say she's a hooker
but there's a certain there's a groupie
type mentality in hollywood
you know what i mean hold on a second uh
tim said what was the name of the book
you read about casey it was called um
everything you didn't know about the
casey anthony trial i think it was
called
it's on um kindle unlimited i read on a
kindle unlimited
she would [ __ ] nicole was playing
with [ __ ] oj's emotions i think
[ __ ] o.j loved her
she was she was [ __ ] him up playing
with his [ __ ] emotions
treating him like a [ __ ] punk and
then she's [ __ ] probably dating other
dudes underneath his nose
he had enough that [ __ ] lost it
and [ __ ] he saw her with that other
dude
and i think he thought that was the
boyfriend i don't think that was the
boyfriend was it no that wasn't our
boyfriend but he
was just a friend of hers he thought it
was and he went [ __ ] ballistic
he had he'd had enough of that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] from what i remember that was a
long time ago that that case happened
but from what i remembered
it uh there was some evidence that
that she was [ __ ] spending a lot of
his money
and uh not really spending a whole lot
of time with him
you know what i mean that's just like i
said that was that
being a shitty person and i know this is
kind of hard for people to like
being a shitty person doesn't mean one
that you're a murderer
or two like in casey anthony's case like
i said she is a shitty person
she's a shitty person that doesn't mean
that she premeditatedly murdered her
daughter
um you know but like i said she's still
a shitty person like because what she
did after the daughter died
the same thing about it is that even as
nicole simpson was a shitty person
yeah that doesn't mean she deserved to
have oj like no
cut her hair but i'm going to tell you
that [ __ ] nicole
nicole was shitty but
[ __ ] oj shitty that's what i mean
well he beat the [ __ ] out of her
yeah he was shitty too so it's like can
you blame her
i don't know i we i wasn't there i mean
i wasn't no i'm just saying like can you
blame her because she did
i mean even like years before she got
murdered
he was probably she was reporting him
for spousal to be first special but was
he slapping a [ __ ] over a domestic
sucking somebody else's dick or whatever
yeah but it's like that's not an excuse
it's like you're my wife why are you
sucking that's not an excuse
that's what i would have said you
shouldn't just like beat the [ __ ] out
you have you have [ __ ] that
can't control their emotions
just right like i said but that's not an
excuse
he was just maybe he was addicted to
that you can't control your emotions
you need to learn you need to learn to
control your emotions
that was a long time that was a long
time ago when i was a kid and i remember
the
the that era you know what i mean and
that was a different time
um that was shocking even back in those
days
but there's more to that there had to be
i know but i feel like they're still
operating on the assumption that you
know
if like oh if a chick is like cheating
on you if she's doing that then like
it's
deserved which that's kind of
problematic i mean it's like just like i
said just because you're a shitty person
that doesn't mean you deserve to get
murdered you know what i mean
because i've written about some people
that did get murdered and they were
shitty people but it's like i'm not
saying
they deserved what they got because they
obviously
they didn't but you know that that
doesn't make it
better you know what i'm saying yeah
pepper said are you guys gonna do
something on the zodiac killer cipher we
talked about it like
uh at the beginning of the show if you
were not here we did say that the zodiac
uh cipher 340 or whatever it's called uh
has been solved and
as we suspected well as i suspected
anyway it doesn't say anything at all
interesting it's just like some more
[ __ ] that
it's more of the [ __ ] that he always
said are we ever gonna find out who that
[ __ ] was
he's dead well i'm sure he's dead but
it's like it would be cool if they could
at least be like hey
this is him although would it ruin the
mystique
because i feel like zodiac is one of
those killers that
he's still this big mystery him and the
phantom killer i guess
because they both like wore masks so
it's like you never
know i almost feel like people like it
better
if they don't know who he is because if
if you find out who it is it'll just
just be
inevitably like some schlub it's like uh
that's him
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying it's
almost kind of like
when original nightstalker got caught
joseph d'angelo
and everybody's like ah that's it it's
like this just this
like fatal fart [ __ ] that it's not fun
anymore
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah i'm
thinking about that curry i'm not
thinking about all that
you're thinking about the curry yeah
what time is it
it is 8 22. damn
it actually pretty early yeah it's
pretty early how long has how long has
the show been going on
three hours and 20 years it's still a
three hour show is the case over
well i mean does that mean i can't i
can't remember if i've talked about
everything what i'm talking about
because there were some things that i'm
glad that people in the uh
comments reminded me because it was like
all these little like things that i
wanted to bring up
and like i said i didn't want to make it
seem like i was defending
casey anthony because i'm not i still
think she's a shitty person
yeah but i don't think she's a
premeditated
murderer you know what i'm saying yeah i
think the baby just died
because she wasn't watching her and like
some
you know some bad [ __ ] happened and then
she made the very very stupid decision
allegedly with her and her dad that they
were gonna
cover it up instead of calling the
police which
just kept compounding the error and
making them look even
more and more suspicious but like i said
if you if you read anything about these
people this family the dynamic
of this family is really really messed
up
because like i said the whole [ __ ] about
george and the wife
who had split up for a time and then
they got back together
george said that casey the daughter was
one of the reasons
that him and the wife divorced and i
think it was just because
i don't know if it was because cindy
thought the daughter was a [ __ ] up
and they were having and she wanted the
daughter to be perfect and she was
pretending the daughter wasn't a [ __ ] up
and george was kind of like no but she
is the [ __ ] up so i kind of
because like i said casey is a shitty
person she stole from people she stole
from her friends she stole from her mom
she
took a bunch of money out of their
accounts um i don't know if i mentioned
this earlier but
one of her friends it might have been
amy but i can't remember one of her
friends went off on like
vacation or something and like um casey
was supposed to be like
watching her [ __ ] or doing some [ __ ] for
her while she was gone
and she basically used amy's checkbook
and spent like 300 something dollars
like at target just buying like
[ __ ] food and toilet paper and [ __ ]
like that like she wasn't buying
anything like
you know extravagant she was just buying
like regular [ __ ] but she went to like
target
and spent like a whole bunch of her
friends money
and then when her friend got back and
tried to like pay some bills or try to
do something with their checking account
like all her money was gone
so she did like drown like drain one of
her friend's accounts
like while she was gone so as i said the
friends did know
that she was a compulsive liar
that she was kind of a leech
in the sense that she didn't have a job
so she was always kind of like
hey can you buy me lunch hey can you buy
me some gas hey can you give me a ride
hey
she was one of those kind of people like
we know some people like that so she was
kind of a person like that which like i
said that's
terrible and nobody should be like that
but i'm not saying that that makes her
like a premeditated murderer those are
two
completely different things but the fact
that she reacted so weirdly
to her daughter's death um
you know like i said terrible person
also probably a bunch of mental issues
that probably came from her family
because her family all have horrible
mental issues as well
it's messed up you guys yeah well we're
making a show out of them we don't
really know them but that's
it looks like i'm just saying yeah this
is just my
you know perception of it from the
outside like from
reading you know the trial transcripts
reading
like you know watching interviews with
them and stuff like this is just my
perception of the [ __ ]
the weird thing about it like i said is
that a couple psychologists like
you know um evaluated her and didn't
think there was anything that mattered
with her but i was like i find that hard
to believe
because she seemed like
i don't know if i'd go so far as to say
sociopathic but she
definitely seems like a compulsive liar
because she just lies about stuff that
is not she would invent she not only
invented a nanny
and invented the fact that she had a job
she and she invented like a whole thing
like oh
my an event planner at universal i'm
doing this and
she would like invent details about it
she invented
a boyfriend um the dude was
like apparently a real dude but she said
that
he had a kid named zachary i think the
dude's name was jeff hopkins and she's
like yeah and
me and me and uh jeff we took you know
the baby and we took uh
his kid zachary to the park and we did
this and that and that was uh
that was not true so he she just
invented entire scenarios
she invented entire friends she invented
little friends for kaylee when kaylee
was still alive
so she kind of had this just weird that
was like her default
was that she would just invent stories
even when she didn't have to
so it's i don't know it's just like a
really weird
i find it hard to understand because i
don't have that
pathology i guess so it's really hard
for me to understand somebody
that would just lie about [ __ ] when they
didn't have to lie about [ __ ] because it
seems like a lot of stuff
a lot of the [ __ ] that she lied about
was like [ __ ] that was really easy to
check on
and but she would just keep on with it
you know what i'm saying she would just
like this whole thing about the nanny
that she had
she there was no such person but she
would go
on and on and on with it like an
invent this elaborate scenario
about this woman and where they were
going
we're going to busch gardens we did this
that and the other thing
and then the mom would call and be like
can i talk to kaylee oh well no you
can't because
we decided we were gonna stay in tampa
another day with
the nanny and we're doing this so she
would always like come up with this like
[ __ ] and it was like it's crazy it's
crazy
and i can't understand like people like
that because
i honestly i would get i find a hard
time keeping track of like real [ __ ]
that happens
having to keep track of all of these
elaborate lies that you have going with
all of these different people that you
know
is just sounds exhausting and i don't
really know how you would
maintain it to any degree because how
would you remember all the details like
what did i tell
what lie did i tell this person and what
lie did i tell that person
and it's like you have to keep it all
straight like how do you keep it all
straight
why would you do that to yourself i
don't understand it
but i'm not a crazy person so i don't
really know
khan is asking me what i mean what am i
eating for dinner
dude i got some i got some chicken curry
in there
yellow chicken curry in there with curry
leaves tomatoes
i got it on warm man i'm [ __ ] i'm
ready to eat some of that
you're ready to eat it i'm ready to eat
it yeah
[Laughter]
i'm starving he's getting hungry all
right so we better
i think we can wrap this up shut it down
we can shut it down the show's been
three something hours
i mean like i said i didn't go super
into like all the details but i feel
like
most people know like the little
intricate details of the [ __ ] so i
kind of wanted to get into some of the
[ __ ] that i read about it and like some
of the fascinating [ __ ] that i came up
with because
the psychology of these people just like
kind of fascinates me like why
i understand like why they would act the
way they would act
but in another way i can't understand it
because i don't have that
psychopathology i guess so it's like to
me it just seems really weird
and like to a lot of people it would
seem really weird because the way they
react to [ __ ] is not the way that normal
people would react
so i get that like i said i'm not
forgiving her i do think that she should
have done some prison time at least for
negligent homicide because i
definitely think that she knew what
happened and she wasn't paying attention
and some bad should happen and then she
covered it up which was stupid
but what are you gonna do so all right
um oh last podcast did a good casey
anthony show i actually haven't listened
to that yet i listened to this um
a couple other ones like uh i think like
there was a whole bunch of like um
you know documentaries like [ __ ] you
know the id channel and [ __ ] like that i
watched all those and then
like i said stephanie harlow did a four
and a half hour three-part series on it
that was really good
um i usually look for last podcast on
the left because i like those guys
but i didn't see their one on this one
so i'll have to maybe watch that
tomorrow because i did
actually find this really fascinating
but there were a couple books about it
like i said i think the one that i read
there was a couple different ones that i
read but the one that i really liked was
i think it's called everything you
didn't know about the casey anthony
trial
i can't remember who wrote it but if you
look on
amazon look on kindle unlimited because
that's how i have the subscription so i
read it for free like the ebook
and i read that one and that was
somebody that was like looking at
it wasn't like a whole overview of the
trial but they were just kind of like
talking about like the little
intricacies of the case like the whole
thing about the trunk and the whole
thing about
the duct tape and like they kind of went
into all the [ __ ] that was uh
said at the trial and they were pointing
out all various things about it it was
really interesting
so uh i would recommend that one i can't
remember what the other one that i wrote
was called but yeah so
like look into that but i don't know
what casey anthony's up to nowadays
like i said after her sexy movie
about her truth i don't know what the
[ __ ] was the name
like the title of it was so
oh man what was the title of that movie
that they were gonna make if
ah [ __ ] it wasn't if i did it that was
oj
but it was something like that you know
what i'm saying i don't remember it
it was uh [ __ ] i can't remember what it
is now but it was something like bulls
that like if you heard it you would just
like roll your eyes and be like really
[ __ ] okay whatever but it was it was
that kind of thing and the fact that her
and oj were gonna do a reality show
when somebody thought that was a good
idea i mean i'm sure everybody would
watch it
just for you know because everybody'd be
curious
but i'm just saying if they had made the
movie i probably would have watched it
but i wouldn't have paid for it
i would have just pirated it because you
don't want to give anybody money you
don't want to like encourage
that behavior but you still want to see
it so
i'm just saying all right so we're going
to wrap up
this episode and go eat some curry yeah
i'm [ __ ] starving
so hopefully you guys are doing it i'm
getting quiet which that's that's a sign
that the uh
the son of tequila's taking taking over
the tequila is taking
this take it off now he's more true than
man he's more tequila than man yeah i
don't watch it man
if i don't watch it [ __ ] seagal is
going to come after me
i won't be able to defend myself under
this [ __ ] blood alcohol level
i think you're still safe at this point
um
like i said he might still sit on your
head and he might suffocate you
which that'd be bad but i could probably
push him over
thank you we got something thank you
victor victor jenny fan club membership
cool
all right so we're still pretty coherent
that's pretty good
all right so remember
if you like the show please like share
subscribe if you haven't already i'm
sure most of you have
uh if you'd like to financially support
the show and you haven't already go to
our patreon page patreon.com.clomp
whatever.com
yeah oh patreon.com 13 o'clock
podcast and you can give a small monthly
donation you get to like
vote on polls about what the next movie
is going to be move your retrospective
what the next episode is going to be
all kind of [ __ ] like that it's super
fun you get early access to all the
episodes all the recorded episodes at
least
and uh [ __ ] like that and also if you
would like to
financially support the show but you
don't like patreon go to paypal
uh which you can go to our blog which is
13 o'clock podcast at wordpress.com go
to our paypal account there's a button
in the sidebar
you can give a one-time donation if
you'd like to do that and as always we
will see you guys
tomorrow we'll do another live stream
probably a movie review
uh we've already watched the movie so i
already know what it's going to be
so come back tomorrow and see our hang
hungover asses talking about a movie
that we saw on netflix
so we'll see you guys tomorrow and bye